welcome to a alt shift X live stream to
discuss House of the Dragons season 1
episode 6. we're going to talk about the
episode we're going to answer your
questions we are not going to spoil
future episodes
and there is so much to talk about today
uh welcome to the year of the red spring
this that's what they call it in the
books there's there's a year after 10
years of not a whole lot happening
there's one year where everything starts
to go terribly wrong and uh this is the
beginning of that we had the death of
Lena valarion the wife of Daemon
Targaryen we had the death of Lord
Lionel strong and Harwin strong brake
Bones the family of Lara strong and
we've got more conflict happening
between the children of Alison and the
children of Rainier and [ __ ] starting to
get real welcome to the live stream I've
got the family tree up here because I
want to clarify who's who we've jumped
forwards in time by 10 years a bunch of
the actors have been replaced and recast
to older versions of themselves and I'm
sure a lot of people are a bit confused
about about who's who
um so
rhaenyra and Lenor got married 10 years
ago in the previous episode and they've
had three children ostensibly jiserus
luceris and baby Joffrey and supposedly
these are the children of Lenor and
Rainier but really these are the
children of Harwin break bones strong
and rhaenyra which is a little bit of a
problem because Jose and luceris and
Joffrey other heirs to the Iron Throne
after Rainier
and when you have Bastards of false
parentage in line to the throne you get
disputes it's a lot like when Cersei and
Jaime Lannister in Game of Thrones had
their bastard to incestuous Children
Joffrey Marcella and tommen and they
were in line to the throne and that that
resulted in some problems as well
although if there's any like
joffrey-like character in the show uh
it's probably Alison's children isn't it
because Allison at King viserys have now
had three children aegon Helena and
amond
and uh in the words of Allison's new
actor Olivia Cook they're all they're
all weird they're all bloody weird aegon
we saw masturbating out a window
you just wanted to get a bit of sunlight
on his on his bits I guess uh aegon we
saw masturbating out a window was that
the same window that tommen commits
suicide out of 170 years later or was at
a different balcony we saw aegon and and
he is is Alison's first-born son and I
love how he doesn't care about the
throne that Alison wants him to have
and then Helena is like a weird bug girl
Helena we saw like playing with a
millipede or something and she had a box
full of scorpions and things and
Allison's just like man my daughter's
weird uh and then amond is like the
younger boy and he's the only one who
doesn't have a dragon so let's do a
little dragon accounting shall we uh who
are the dragons in the story right now
here they are so
uh aegon Targaryen the firstborn son of
Alison and viserys has Sunfire they
mentioned Sunfire in this episode Lena
uh has or had Vega the biggest dragon in
the world uh Helena has a dream fight I
think I think they mentioned that Elena
has dreamfire uh rhaenyra has Cyrax
uh the boys josaris and luceris have
Vermax and araks like we saw these young
dragons that the kids have now
and we saw that oh what another one here
is that
um Baylor Targaryen the child of Lena
and Daemon Baylor Targaryen has a dragon
but Rayna Targaryen the other child of
Daemon and Elena does not
which I think I think is an interesting
dynamic because that is sort of
that fits with the book law but they
don't really explore that but it kind of
makes sense as a thing in their
relationship Baylor does have a dragon
but Reyna's dragon egg didn't hatch and
so there's this sort of like jealousy or
like you know feeling left out that
Reina feels she feels like she's not
accepted as much by her father because
she doesn't have a dragon which is all
all interesting Dynamics
um
so yeah there's a lot to talk about
there's a lot going on
so let's get into it
thanks for the Super Chat from
Inquisitor who says I really didn't like
Lena's death I don't get why she decided
to burn herself
it felt like pointless shock value yeah
I also have mixed feelings about the
death of Lena valerion
um
how did that go down so you know we saw
Lena was very pregnant she was in pentos
with her husband Daemon
um and when the birth started happening
it went badly like births tend to do in
House of the dragon and so then Lena
like knowing that she was going to die
decided that instead of just dying in
the birthing bed she wanted to die like
a Valerian she is Lena valarion she is
the blood of the Dragon she doesn't want
to die in the birthing bed like Emma
Aaron did and so she decides to go out
and command her Dragon Veigar to burn
her to death which is incredibly metal
and Incredibly dark and shocking it is
sort of based on what happens in the
books like the books say that Lena
valerion just dialed died in childbirth
but it says that like as she was dying
she went out to try to ride her Dragon
Vega one last time before she died
um
so you know she did have that desire for
a dragon and it reminds me of like uh
one of King joharis's children called
Daenerys Targaryen it's a different
Daenerys Targaryen but she was dying of
a disease called the Shivers and when
she was dying her
um father the Old King jahiris said she
might get her a dragon get her a dragon
she must have a dragon and it's sort of
this belief or this implication that
targaryens like their connection to
their dragon can make them stronger and
might save them from Death or like
there's a feeling that it that it so it
might restore a Targaryen
so in the books I think there's the
suggestion that you know Lena in the
books when she's dying of childbirth she
goes out to a dragon and she wants to
get strength from her Dragon but in this
case she goes out to a dragon to die and
I think that you know like it's such a
dark thing but it kind of fits with the
idea of you know like Targaryen or
rather you know Valyrian
self-destruction like there's this idea
that targaryens are just fire they are
destructive not only to the people
around them but also to themselves
um and so
self-destruction of someone who is of
the Dragon Blood
makes a lot of sense to me and uh and it
also is so gorgeous that we got to see
Vega and I loved Vega's reluctance to
kill Lena like Lena kept saying dracaris
drakaris and vegar kept refusing to kill
her master
which I think speaks to the connection
you know
um and vegar of course is such a
wonderful monster oldest and biggest
dragon in the world used to be the
dragon of Queen visenya Targaryen who
conquered Westeros alongside aegon Vega
burned the crap out of dawn for years
and years after the death of rhaenys and
maraxis Vega has fought in many wars and
now he's very sort of old and sleepy
kind of begrudges being dragged along
with everyone's new Wars but um yeah my
God it was uh it's amazing to say Vega
uh raziath in the live chat says I'm not
a fan of her death but I understand she
wanted to die like a dragon rider and
wanted to take her own agency
yeah yeah I mean there's definitely that
idea of like women being frustrated with
the Perils of biology
um and wanting to take some agency over
that
fits I guess I I got some I got some
sort of mixed messages with
fire
in this episode because like there was
like this air show this wonderfully
ridiculous air show where Daemon and
Lena flew their dragons over pentos just
as entertainment for the pentachi below
them and you know Daemon was like riding
his dragon without any hands and then
Lena got vegar to like do this burst of
flame and then Daemon flew curraxis
through the flame which is like
wouldn't you die because like it's
confusing because there's this idea in
the original Game of Thrones show where
Daenerys was fireproof on like several
occasions in Game of Thrones Daenerys
survived being immolated in fire
um in the books Daenerys is not
fireproof but in the Game of Thrones
show she is apparently so it's like so
when Daemon like flew through this fire
and was unscathed I was like well are
they saying that Daemon Targaryen is
fireproof is that is that what's
happening
um but then Lena died of fire with Vega
so it's I don't know I feel like that
might confuse people
um as far as I can tell the only person
who's fireproof in the Game of Thrones
show universe is Daenerys not anyone
else as far as I can tell
um so yeah that was uh that was really
intense Elena's death
thanks for the Super Chat from Alex who
says is it possible that jacaris is the
child of Kristen Cole and Rainier
yeah so
so rhaenyra has these three children and
two of them are these are these boys
jiserus and luceris and they obviously
do not look like raniera Targaryen or
Lena or valerion they look a lot more
like Harwin strong who is their like
actual father
um and one of the interesting sort of
changes that the show introduces is this
idea that you know rhaenyra had sex with
Kristen Cole and then maester Melrose
brought rhaenyra Moon tea
um
and we don't see if Rainier drinks the
moon tea or not so I guess it is
possible that
jacaris Valerian rhaenyra's firstborn
child is actually the son of Kristen
Cole I don't I don't think that's what
they're going for because like joserus
and luceris look so similar they look
like they have the same father and the
father is Harwin break bones
um I don't think they're going for the
idea that Kristen Cole is secretly just
heiress's father but like I said it's an
interesting idea I don't know if the
timeline adds up like I don't know if
joserus is meant to be uh 10 years old
I don't think I don't think we'll
benefit from doing the math but um yeah
it's an interesting idea I like the idea
that Jose might be Kristen Cole's son I
don't think it's true but I think it's a
fun interesting idea I also like I
really enjoyed this opening sequence
where rhaenyra gives birth to Joffrey
valarion and
immediately after giving birth she's
forced to make this like walk of shame
because Alison demands to see Joffrey
valerion immediately after his birth and
you know seeing the sort of like
biological uh grisly details of the
childbirth followed immediately by this
walk through the court where they're all
gawked at by all the courtiers and all
the Lords and Ladies and I I think just
that visual contrast between like the
intimate bloody physical moment of
childbirth and then the sort of like
fake public court life
um because I think this whole show in so
many ways is about the sort of conflicts
and the juxtaposition between political
appearances and sort of like real
personal
bloody realities you know
um one of the one of the ideas they
talked about constantly through this
episode was the idea of eyes and the
idea of seeing things uh and blindness
like Helena with her bugs was saying
that this bug is blind I can't see
anything and they were saying oh viserys
is like willfully blind because everyone
is sort of expected to pretend to not
see that Jose and luceris are Harwin
breakbones as children and rhaenyra
needs to sort of push this lie that her
children were fathered by Lenor and
Allison to feel like feels like she's
being gaslit like Alison is like hey it
is so obvious the juiceros and luceras
and Joffrey are the bastard children of
Harwin strong she's breaking the rules
and no one's acknowledging it because
viserys just wants to pretend that
everything's fine viserys just wants to
believe that that Rainier is going to
take the throne there's going to be no
conflict but everyone is being like
willfully blind to the inevitable
conflict that is coming down upon them
and Alison is like this is crazy Alison
feels like she's the one person who's
who's saying the truth and no one is
listening to her
and I I think that I think that works
because Allison is someone who has
always followed the rules but and you
know all of her power and all of her
sort of identity is tied tied up in
following the rules of this power
structure so she's Furious when rhaenyra
openly Breaks the Rules and gets away
with it and Alison hates like the
unfairness of that and I think again
like her color being green her Envy of
rhaenyra is a huge part of this
and I thought it was so interesting that
at the small Council Rainier got up and
said like hey
let's fix this I will marry
um I will marry my firstborn son and
heir
to your daughter Helena let's fix this
conflict let's unite our houses and
Allison said no
so Rainier is like well then fine I'll
I'll go off to Dragonstone but I feel
like that really gives Rainier the moral
High Ground like rhaenyra offered peace
rhaenyra offered peace and unity to
Alison and Alison said no
so I feel like Alison seems more like
the villain here than Rainier but also
like rhaenyra was catastrophically
dumb Honestly by having three kids with
Harwin strong I mean it's like Alison
said like one bastard child would be one
thing but having three is an insult to
us all like if if Rainier and Lenor just
had at least at least one child at least
their firstborn child if at least
rhaenyra's Heir was the trueborn child
of rangiora and Lena everyone would be a
bit safer
but Rainier is
catastrophically bad decision to have
three bastard children with Harwin
creates so much disruption and potential
for conflict in the real family so I
guess that is how you could take the
perspective that rhaenyra is more to
blame for all of this so I mean tell me
in the chat do you think that rhaenyra
or Alison is more the villain here
and I mean I guess the elephant in the
room is that Laris bloody strong is is
the villain here
um so in the books the deaths of Harwin
and Lionel in the fire at Harren Hall it
is ambiguous some people say that Daemon
killed
Lionel and Harwin at harrenhal so that
like Daemon could remove his rival for
Rainier's affections and some people say
that viserys started the fire at
harrenhal to kill Harwin to end the
rumors about uh the parentage of the
children
um I think Otto Hightower is suggested
as the person who started the fire so
that he could become hand again but in
the TV show they're saying that Lara
strong started the fire so that he could
um so that he could remove
Lionel strong so that Otto could become
hand so that Otto could support Allison
but also like larus killing his father
Harwin and killing his bro sorry killing
his father Lionel and killing his
brother Harwin that makes Laris the Lord
of harrenhal that means that lariss is
now the leader of how strong so larus is
not only doing Alison a favor that's how
he sees it anyway but he's also making
himself a lord of the biggest castle in
harrenhall so he's making himself more
powerful and like I love how Allison
says dude that's crazy I did not want
you to murder
and Lionel she's saying I did not want
this but Lara said yeah you do yeah you
did so like Laris is sort of dragging
Alison into villainy like Laris is
almost making Alison culpable
for the deaths of Lionel and Harwin
um so he's almost you know dragging her
along with him into the darkness you
know I don't know I
thought that was really crazy
um
Jim filbert in a Super Chat says is
suicide by Dragon a thing ever in the
books I I can't think of any examples of
someone
commanding their own dragon to kill them
no I mean some people have done some
suicidally stupid things to get
themselves killed by dragons but not
like by command I mean if if I was to
write a little bit of fanfic the way I
the way I might have done it uh
would be wouldn't it be cool if Lena
like goes out to Vega and knows that
she's gonna die what if instead of like
commanding Vega to burn her what if she
just went on one last flight on Vega
like what if she climbed onto Vega's
back they flew up into the year and then
Lena just sort of allowed herself to
slip off Vega
and fell to her death would that be
cooler would that be less cool I don't
know I because I feel like the flight
itself is is always what is beautiful
and fun about the Dragon Rider
connection
um and I think a flight on Vega is what
Lena wanted in the books specifically
and allowing herself to sort of slip off
gracefully I think would have this sort
of tragedy to it but I mean it is a lot
more pointed and a lot more shocking and
a lot more intense to look death in the
face and to command Vega to burn her
that's a lot more dramatic and direct as
well I guess
thanks for the Super Chat from Ash
nightable who says is the stat about
half of dragon eggs not hatching
anywhere close to real I remember euron
not being able to hatch an egg but
that's about it
there's not a lot of statistics about uh
dragon egg hatch rights in House of the
Dragon uh this is not Pokemon that we
have not got the RNG laid out for us in
the books they don't say there's a lot
of ambiguity about exactly like who gets
dragon eggs when do the eggs the hatch
but I like how they did explore that
because I liked how we had that
conversation between Lena valarion and
her daughter Raina where she was saying
well you know like sometimes this works
in different ways sometimes the egg is
in your cradle and it hatches and you
bond with the dragon hatchling but other
times you claim a dragon when you're
older so in the same way that Lena
didn't bond with a dragon hatchling she
instead claimed Vega when she was older
apparently there there was a deleted
scene originally where young Lana bonded
with Vega but they removed the scene for
some reason
which is unfortunate but um but yeah
there's more than one way to get a
dragon but one of the important rules to
keep in mind is that no human has ever
bonded with multiple dragons
um like viserys Road balerion the black
dread but then Valerian died and viserys
never bonded with another dragon dragons
can bond with multiple humans because
dragons live longer than humans uh but
humans only ever bond with one dragon
thanks for the Super Chat from Philippe
who said what did you think of the
portrayal of larus he seemed more subtle
last episode I like the change yeah well
I feel like larys is is is not subtle uh
now like in the books it is never clear
like what larus wants or what exactly
Laris did and did not do you know who
what what game he's really playing
whereas here in the show they're really
like shoving it in your face that he's
the guy who did the murders
um and you know I guess that makes sense
like the that they're trying to tell us
what's going on they're trying to remove
some of their ambiguity
um
I I I kind of would like it if there was
more subtlety but as I said I do love
her his relationship with Alison where
it's like is she using him or is he
using her you know I guess it's I guess
that's a bad thing if it sort of takes
away Allison's agency you know like if
Laris just does evil things on Alison's
behalf and she just goes along with it
it's like well what is Alison even doing
here you know
um but I guess she's choosing to keep
him around like Alison could dismiss
larus at any moment
it was cool to see larys in the dungeons
we saw larus like
um recruit these death row prisoners to
be his uh to be his Tools in this fire
it's kind of funny that he also gives
Laris gives the prisoners this little is
that like a scarab beetle or a cicada he
gives them this little bug sigil this
little pin to identify them as his
minions which seems like a very bad idea
when you're doing a top secret arson
murder job right why would you want why
would you want your cat's paws to be
wearing your symbol that doesn't really
make sense but it's a visual thing for
the viewers to say that that that bug is
like larice's symbol I mean Laris is so
reminiscent of Littlefinger Littlefinger
with his Laris uh with his Mockingbird
sigil very similar
and of course uh larys talks about the
curse of Harren hall because there is
this history of houses going extinct
anyone who has Haron Hall soon loses it
um harrenhall has such a dark history
because harrenhal was built by slave
labor by Haron the black and thousands
of riverlanders died in its construction
blood in the mortar and then the day
that Harwin uh the day that harrenhor
finished completing Harren Hall uh aegon
the Conqueror landed on Westeros and all
of all of harrenhor's evil work in
building the castle was immediately
pointless because aegon the Conqueror
came and burned him and so it's a sort
of like an Ozymandias Testament to the
futility of human hubris that we build
these giant monuments but they uh they
don't last in the way that we want them
to
thanks for the Super Chat from Neff
nephrarat who says I'm such a big fan
and you helped me get through all my
work days I was so impressed with the
episode thanks nephrarette thanks for
the Super Chat from Anthony who says how
does amond not have an egg but the baby
does do they only get eggs from their
parents dragons well there was like an
interesting conversation where there was
a it was a funny bit where Rainier was
like oh and like we will give
um Alison and her children some dragon
eggs like she offered for for a marriage
between Elena and jacaris and she also
said and we'll give you some dragon eggs
so I guess it sounds like maybe
Allison's faction don't have as many
dragon eggs lying around I think the
implication is that a lot of the dragons
and the dragon eggs are on Dragonstone
but also there'd be some of the Dragon
pit yeah maybe most of them are at the
dragon pit yeah it's not exactly clear
who has dragons and who doesn't but like
maybe what happened with amond was that
amond was given a dragon egg when he was
in the Cradle but that dragon egg didn't
hatch because like Lena told us this
episode that only 50 of dragon eggs
hatch so maybe just like with Rayna
targaryen's dragon egg non-hatching
um maybe aemon's dragon egg also didn't
hatch and yeah it was a really funny
moment when uh when amon's brother
uh aegon gave amond a little uh Pig
with some wings on it the pink dread to
mock amount and and I quite I was a
little bit surprised but I quite like
that you know aegon bullies amond as
much as jiserus and luceris do so like
it's not just you know uh Alison's
children against Rainier as children
um aegon is just a dick to everyone and
I thought it was so funny when Alison
came and you know aegon was masturbating
out a window and Alison was saying hey
you are the king you will be the heir
and he's like oh I don't care like
whatever I just want to like masturbate
out the window mum and she's like you
need to be serious about this and and
it's great because it's like we see how
the parents are pushing the kids into
into conflict like the kids don't want
this but they are being trained to fight
each other they are being given these
weapons of war in the dragons and they
are being trained to fight against each
other by like Kristen and Harwin and we
see like you know the adults are
modeling the conflict that the children
copy you know like Kristen goads Harwin
into beating him up as a way to sort of
reveal harwin's connection as the parent
of just Aries and this Eris
um but we see how the kids are just
learning the conflicts and inheriting
the conflicts and The Grudges from their
children and being given dragons and
it's like they're just setting it all up
but you know again that that theme of
blindness this episode everyone is like
turning a blind eye to the conflict that
they are creating and Alison feels like
she's the only one who sees it and I
guess Rainier also feels like she's the
only one who sees this but but rhaenyra
needs to keep the parentage quiet you
know so
my god
um thanks for the Super Chat from Among
Us law who says do the maesters parallel
the Ben a Jesuit
so the Benny Jesuit are a faction in
Dune who are like these manipulative
witches who use like body control and
mind control and genetic manipulation to
control the universe and uh the maesters
are not that badass The Mazes are not as
powerful as the Benny Jesuit the
maesters are kind of like crotchety old
men who's you know they've got they've
got limits and biases and you know like
some people see the maesters as having
like a big sprawling conspiracy it is
ambiguous I mean like personally I think
that the maesters you know that the
maesters do have a sort of ideological
bias against magic uh we sort of Saw as
much in the prologue chapter of the
second Game of Thrones book at Clash of
Kings there's this character called
Cresson who
um
tries to kill Melisandre
and like we we see
um we see cresson's motivations
explained to us like Crescent says that
you know this this Melisandre she's a
witch she's a menace she's like going
against the Gods like I've got to stop
her black sorcery and like he's a man of
science and he's a maester but it's like
Cresson doesn't say you know this is a
conspiracy he doesn't say oh all of the
old mates at the Citadel were ordering
me to assassinate Melisandre no like I I
don't think it's a big conspiracy but I
do think that like individual maesters
and small groups of maesters are
conspiring and I do think that Melos and
Otto are conspiring to a large extent
because like
um
because Auto and the high Towers they
are the ones who fund the maesters you
know like the main The Citadel of the
maesters is he an Old Town
um it it makes a lot of sense that they
would have connections they would want
each other to succeed so I think that
Melos at least does want to help Otto
Hightower get aegon on the throne
instead of rhaenyra and maybe Melos and
the maesters also want to like maybe you
know
um
and poison a few dragon eggs or
something reduce the number of dragons
in the world but I think that's not like
unique I think that a lot of the Lords
of Westeros want to get rid of the
Dragons because they don't have dragons
like every Lord in Westeros either wants
a dragon or wants no one to have dragons
like because they are power you know
everyone's jealous of power but it seems
as though uh maester Melos is dead now
incidentally I think that now
um maester Melos has died and now we've
got maester Orwell on the ground on the
council
um where's the bloody small Council
scene because we had a small Council
scene
um where rhaenyra offered
to marry
just heiress to Helena
um and we met some new
characters we met we met iron Rod who is
the new master of laws
um
and we met again the new
maester Orwell I guess Orwell is now the
grand maester
anyway thanks for the Super Chat from
Leo who says I loved viserys's face
during Rainier's proposal to Alison yeah
he he like thumped at the table and he
was like ah yeah so most judicious
proposal ah yes good idea like viserys
was just Overjoyed at the prospect of um
his wife and his daughter actually
getting along for once yeah here we are
yeah he is the scene uh yeah viserys was
was really happy at the prospect of like
oh my God maybe my problems will sort
themselves out like I always wanted uh
but Alison rejected it which I think is
is so significant you know like Alison
was offered an olive branch she was
offered the possibility of peace and
Reconciliation and she rejected it you
know and I think that's I think that
kind of makes Alison a villain you know
and I think I think it makes sense that
Alison rejects it because like she
doesn't want to
justify she doesn't want to reward
Rainier is [ __ ] she doesn't want to
marry herself marry her family to her
brother of bastards because Allison
cares so much about the rules like
Alison really believes that you know
what rhaenyra did is wrong
and and yeah the breast milk coming
through Rainier's dress as well like the
indignity of like the biology and
Anatomy being pushed upon her Rainier is
actor Emma Darcy talked about how
Rainier like feels in conflict with her
gender and she feels like gender limits
her and [ __ ] with her and and prevents
her political power much like Cersei
Lannister in Game of Thrones sort of
feels at war with her own gender and
seeing rhaenyra's gender undermine her
in a in a moment of like political
necessity uh I think really sort of fits
with that idea
um meanwhile Alison's actor uh
Olivia Cook was saying that you know
Alison feels like she has always
followed the rules she's always been
perfect she's always towed the line
she's always done what Otto told her to
do and so it's so [ __ ] unjust to her
that rhaenyra who breaks all the rules
gets everything gets away with
everything gets to enjoy life gets
Freedom gets to [ __ ] Harwin on the side
whereas Allison who followed all the
rules and did all the right things does
not feel rewarded for her efforts and
that's a big part of um
what's going on but but you know her
actor Olivia Cook also also like didn't
defend Alison like in the interview she
was saying she was kind of saying that
Alison is not a great person is what her
active was saying in a recent
Entertainment Weekly interview uh quote
rhaenyra can just get away with anything
whereas Allison just had to walk this
tightrope her entire life she looks
around at her family and they're so
effed up she's like I've been so perfect
I haven't taken a step wrong and it
doesn't effing matter she has a complete
existential crisis
um and yeah she also said that her
children are all uh [ __ ] weird she
said
aegon the public masturbator Helena the
bug girl amond the uh dragon fancier so
yeah and and Alison also no it's Olivia
Cook also notes that all of Ellison's
children are like
almost as old as she is because Allison
had these children quite young and she
says that her children are almost as
much like siblings as they are like
children which is one of the sort of
weird grossness one of the weird gross
things about like the ages in this story
and also like you know seeing Alison
care for viserys like viserys is this
you know decrepit dying old man
um and Alison is looking after him
or almost as though she's like um almost
like I mean she sings more like his
child or his grandchild more than his
wife you know the relationship between
viserys and Allison
um
and yeah just that age Gap makes it so
uncomfortable I mean especially thinking
that you know Allison and viserys were
having children while viserys's body is
like disintegrating and you know we saw
how unhappy and uncomfortable Alison was
having sex with viserys when his body
was like covered in sores and like
leprosy and crap
um God I hope we don't get another sex
scene with Alison and viserys
thanks for the Super Chat from the
caveless bear who says love the live
streams part of my Sunday routine
larice's actor nailed that final scene
thanks for the Super Chat from Hells
Bell who said the episode was about the
battleground of motherhood and the
blindness of fathers Lionel ignored
Harwin didn't even catch larus's game
well I mean we did get that argument
between Lionel strong and Harwin where
Lionel was saying like hey you having
sex with Princess rhaenyra puts us all
in danger
um because if it gets found out that you
committed treason by hooking up with
rhaenyra you could be you could be
murdered you could be exiled our whole
house could be punished and so Lionel
tries to do the smart thing which is run
away I really like I really like
Lionel's decision here
because Lionel comes to viserys and says
I quit like I'm leaving
um I I don't even want to say why but
like I'm believing because Harwin is
having sex with the princess and I don't
want my family to be destroyed and and
he's acting out of concern and love for
his son Harwin so you know he takes
Harwin to harrenhal away from Rainier to
prevent the affair from continuing to
get his family out of danger uh but what
he didn't see coming was his son larus
murdering him in the fire at Harren Hall
so you know it's kind of tragic that
Lionel strong Lionel strong is this sort
of unexpected fan favorite I think like
I wasn't expecting Lionel to be this
great dude and the reason why he's a
great dude is that he seems to be the
one guy who who is unbiased and gives
King viserys good advice and and doesn't
like do everything out of his own
self-interest but here he makes this
very reasonable decision where like I
want to protect my family so we're going
back to Harren Hall but then he got
murdered by Laris and and I wonder like
you know like like Lionel was aware that
his son Harwin was having an fair with
rhaeny era
was Lionel completely unaware of what a
[ __ ] murderous weirdo his son larus
is
I don't know like was he blind to Laris
but aware of Owen
thanks for Super Chat from Jess who says
ultimately ifrainira just legitimizes
her sons when she becomes Queen it
shouldn't matter honestly yeah that's a
fair take because like it it kind of
doesn't matter whether Rainier's
children are Leno's children or harwin's
children because the claim doesn't the
claim to the throne doesn't come from
lanor the claim to the throne comes from
rhaenyra from her father King viserys so
like theoretically rhaenyra could just
say uh yeah Jose and luceros and Joffrey
they are the children of Harwin strong
and as the new Queen I will legitimize
them because that's something that
rulers can do they can make bastards
into not bastards like our Ramsay Snow
in Game of Thrones became Ramsay Bolton
he was legitimized so theoretically if
if queen rhaenyra or if viserys just
legitimized these children as um as the
true as then theoretically it would all
be hunky-dory uh but realistically
people do have
people would people would take issue
with that I mean people might argue that
like how and strong is not a Highborn or
respectable enough person I mean he is
Highborn but they might argue that he's
not respectable enough or they might
they might argue that Rainier is a
harlot and a Slaton for for having you
know adulterous sex and you know
obviously the valerians would be
outraged because Corliss valerion is so
interested in his like families pride
and Legacy
um I I think Carlos would be furious if
Rainier said that yeah I cucked your son
like I think that would be an issue
um so there's a lot of like delicate
issues so as much as we can say oh she
should just legitimize them uh I don't
think it would be that easy and you know
of course that you know just just again
connects to the theme of you know
intimate sexuality and intimate
relationships
um being
conflated and connected to Grand
political issues and Wars like like
isn't it fundamentally just crazy that
who Dex who is of National Security
importance you know like the fate of
this continent depends on who dicks who
that is absurd that is crazy but that
was like you know a reality for large
chunks of human history and you know is
still a reality in a lot of ways for a
lot of people
um I think just sort of the the
absurdity of that and the pain of that
is is
um part of what this show is about and I
liked how
they emphasized the blood when rhaenyra
birthed her son Joffrey like she had
blood on her and the baby had blood on
her like now and like even as she's
going up to see Allison and viserys the
blood is everywhere and that of course
connects to like the motifs of the
opening sequence because the opening
sequence is all about blood as like the
bloodline and blood connecting to life
and death and childbirth and violence
and War it's all connected and I really
liked Lenor in this episode as well as
sort of the long-suffering beard husband
like you know he is playing the role of
rhaenyra's faithful husband
when in reality she's screwing with
Harwin and he's screwing with his new
boyfriend Carl Corey
um and I thought it was you know like he
stumbles in drunk while Rainier is
trying to just like deal with politics
and her baby and everything and Lena's
just drunk and he's like ah I'm I want
to go off to a war I want to go and get
some some sapphires on the stepstones I
want to go have a good time
um and Rainier is frustration with that
but I mean Leno is also putting up with
a lot like you know Lenor is allowing
rhaenyra to cheat she's allowing him to
cheat
I don't I like his performance I I
thought it was an interesting change how
you know Lane order does have this sort
of
um
ridiculous sort of fun-loving indulgent
sort of decadent thing I guess like
rhaenyra is saying like all you've been
doing is indulging yourself for these 10
years but Lena also has this
um pride and he says that you know I am
a knight I am a warrior and that is sort
of a change that they made from the
books like in the books they say that
Lenor only got knighted a couple of
weeks before his wedding terrain era
because it was sort of seen as the
proper thing to do for him to be a
knight which implies that he's not much
of a warrior in the books whereas in the
show he is which I think is an
interesting change
um and yeah the stepstones are becoming
an issue again uh because like you know
Daemon went and killed the crab feeder
um back in episode X and now the
stepstones continue to be a problem
turns out when you do a military
intervention on some foreign land and
kill a bunch of people and then leave
sometimes it becomes a [ __ ] show again a
few years later uh and Rainier is saying
like we should have actually like done
something to hold this land and like
viserys is like oh my God like do we do
we still have to deal with this crap is
for Sarah's missing more fingers
how many fingers does viserys have now
we need to do like a viserys finger
count has he lost more fingers
I don't know he's very he's very unwell
he's very unwell
uh yes Harwin strong is dead people in
the live chat are confused lahawan
strong and Lionel strong are dead Lara
strong is the sole survivor of the
strong family
um gear check in the live chat says that
viserys has only one arm now is he
missing an arm
say I was trying so hard to count the
fingers that I couldn't count oh that's
uh that's iron Rod by the way new master
of laws mushroom says that iron Rod was
um
he does not have the arm did he did he
did did he miss an arm and I didn't
notice you know that uh psychology uh
experiment where like they show people
the video of like the basketball players
and then the gorilla Moon walks through
the frame and people don't even see the
gorilla because they're so focused on
the basketball players I was so focused
on viserys's fingers that I didn't
notice his missing arm
um I guess I'll take your word for it
guys I I guess viserys must be missing
an arm
we'll keep an eye out
missing an arm my God that's a downer uh
anyway uh thanks for the Super Chat from
tambilay who says Alison has gone crazy
she doesn't even realize how blinded by
rage she has become and also poisoning
her son's mind creep in the making yeah
I thought it was so telling and so funny
and so crazy that like Alison walks in
on her son masturbating out a window and
what she says is not hey son stop doing
that weird gross [ __ ] and behave
yourself no she comes in and says aegon
you need to start a war and take the
throne and and make conflict and it's
like what kind of parenting is that
you're not worried about the public
indecency but you are worried about him
not starting enough Wars like yeah
Alison is really like creating conflict
because like aegon is like getting along
with uh joserys and luceris
um I mean admittedly he's bullying his
brother amond but
yeah I I don't think Allison is doing a
great job with her kids but her kids are
pretty uh uh effing weird as the actor
said
um
yeah my God but this is all about how
parents push kids into
bad situations and conflicts and that's
what they were doing in this Dragon pit
scene like giving the kids these weapons
teaching them to kill you know giving
them the goat to burn teaching the kids
to enjoy violence like this shot in
particular is so disturbing because we
hear the Sheep I thought it was a goat
was it a sheep or a goat we see the
animals squealing in pain as it's being
burned alive and we see the smile on the
kid's face is that luceros or joserus
the smile on the kid's face and it's
like they are training these children to
be killers and it's horrifying I also
enjoyed this Dragon pit guy who only
spoke Valerian like he was speaking
Valerian and then one of the other
Dragon pit people was translating and
it's like where's this guy from that he
doesn't
know the common tongue but he does speak
Valerian like is he just like Dragon pit
for life like does he just talk to
dragons all day in Valerian and not
speak any common tongue I want to know
what this guy's story is he's got all
these scars on his face do you think
that's connected to like dragon fire
bones like surely bones are an
occupational hazard for the dragon pit
fable
and yeah I also liked seeing like after
aemond was was bullied and mocked with
the pig
um aemond went down into the depths of
the Dragon pit alone and he encountered
some giant dragon and then he ran away
it reminds me a bit of um
Quentin Martell in the books decides
that he's gonna get a dragon for himself
he goes down into marine and he um tries
to take one of daenerys's dragons and it
doesn't work very well for him so I hope
that aemond is more successful in
attaining a dragon than Quentin Martel
was
um
thanks for the Super Chat from Ben who
says that Laris is definitely walking
into those rats yeah they had another
little rodent make an appearance and it
sort of did connect to Laris didn't it
um
because we had like King viserys hanging
out playing playing Warhammer 40K
um and then you know he's looking at the
ring which it's a Targaryen ring I
thought it was going to be Emma Aaron's
Aaron ring but no he's looking at a
Targaryen ring I guess well he kisses it
maybe maybe it is Emma Aaron's ring that
there was a really interesting interview
I think it was with Sarah Hess one of
the writers and producers who said that
the main reason why viserys wants
Rainier to inherit the throne is because
rhaenyra is all viserys has left of his
wife Emma Aaron and for viserys it's
like making Rainier air is like an act
of love to his wife Emma and almost like
an apology for getting Emma killed by
keeping on getting her pregnant even
after uh it was increasingly risky to
her health
um so one of the writers said that like
viserys it's all about his wife Emma
with him and his relationship to Rainier
anyway but like wild viserys was like
meccan on the ring this he yeah he used
is he he's missing an entire arm isn't
he I can't believe I didn't notice he
was missing an entire arm anyway so so
the mouse goes along the mantle face
um and then shortly after we cut to the
burning of harrenhal and larys so I
think the mouse is is a symbol of Laris
for sure and as we talked about in the
most recently explained video
um there is a theory
uh most most popularly advanced by a
YouTuber Joe magician about how Lara
strong might be a green Seer and I
really like that theory like I don't
know if that's what they're gonna do in
House of the Dragon but I do like that
idea that larys is a greens here I kind
of hope that they do do it like it is a
bit goofy it is a lot but I kind of hope
that they do it because like you know
one of the one of the differences
between a house of the Dragons House of
the dragon and Game of Thrones is that
house of the Dragon is leaning a bit
more into the magic stuff than Game of
Thrones was Game of Thrones sort always
felt sort of embarrassed to be a fantasy
show whereas House of the Dragon is
doing the Targaryen dreams
um and the mysticism and the Valyrian
stuff and I hope that I hope we get a
bit more magic as it goes on
uh thanks for the Super Chat from Jack
who says did Daemon learn to finish it
seems like he really loved Lena in his
own way yeah I I thought Daemon and
Lena's relationship was interesting I I
thought that they did like an
interesting take with it because like
Daemon the whole time that we've known
him has been always disconsolate always
Restless always rude always constantly
out doing [ __ ] because he was just
never happy with his life and he was
always trying to change things but
whereas now we see this sort of opposite
situation where Daemon had sort of
convinced himself that you know he was
content he was trying to be contempt he
was trying to stay still he was trying
to be away from King's Landing and away
from his family and all of the stuff
that was the source of his frustrations
and so he sort of says that yeah like
[ __ ] it like let's just live in pentos
let's just be here and Damon is trying
to convince himself that he's content
here
I mean even his clothing like he's
wearing this like pentoshi clothing it
looks like this casual wear he's he's
wearing some dad pajamas he's he's
trying to grow a dad be a gut he's like
trying to like I'm just gonna chill I'm
just gonna Grill
that's all I'm gonna do uh but but Lena
is the one telling Daemon hey we are
Dragon Riders we are the blood of
valyria we need to be part of the Royal
Court we need to seize our Birthright we
need to have power and it's so funny
because like Daemon needs to be told
that at this point because previously
Daemon was the guy who was like I am the
Valyrian I want power I want to fight
and so you know what it seems to me is
that Damon is attempting to be content
but but he kind of knows that it's
[ __ ] like Damon kind of knows that
he can't ever be satisfied with sitting
in the ass end of pentos just reading
books and Grilling all day like he knows
that's not gonna work for him and I
think Lena knows that too
but they described it in the inside the
episode as like a marriage that is
slowly breaking down
um like you can see that you know they
are neither of them are really happy
because Leno wants to go back and and be
a valerion
and I think Daemon does too deep down
it's just that Daemon has suffered too
much pain
um in King's Landing and in the politics
he attempted to get away but I think
what what we're seeing is that he can't
stay away
I think Damon's going to come back he he
can't find satisfaction but I mean yeah
like I mean he must have found some
satisfaction in his relationship with
Lena and I do wish we got to see a
little bit more of like how that worked
for him
um what did Lena have that Rainier
and Raya
and mazaria couldn't give him
and I think maybe the answer is like
Valerian children because it was really
interesting that in the conversation
between Lena and her child Raina she was
saying that like Raina was saying that
oh my dad doesn't like pay attention to
me
um he just like hangs out with Baylor
because Baylor has a dragon
um
so like maybe yeah father ignores me
Rayna says so I think that you know
maybe part of what Daemon is all about
in this family is that he really likes
he really values the Valyrian Dragon
riding power stuff so even as he is
trying to act like he doesn't care about
his legacy I think he really does care
about his legacy I mean there are a lot
of connections between Daemon and maegor
Targaryen The cruel who is like his
great great grandfather or something
um Daemon son of Balon grandson of
joharis
um and great grand nephew of of King
maegor the cruel that's that's maegor up
here because maegor interestingly also
was exiled to pentos
um and maegor also wielded dark sister
the Valyrian steel sword that Daemon has
and maegor married Six Wives just like
Daemon said that he wanted to marry
multiple wives
um and viserys explicitly Compares or
Emma explicitly Compares Daemon to mego
so there's like there's a lot of of
direct and indirect connections between
maegor and Daemon which is very ominous
because maegor is universally regarded
as an absolute piece of [ __ ] he was just
this violent monster
um but one of the one of the significant
things about maegor is that he never
managed to reproduce he kept marrying
all these wives and blaming his
reproductive failures on them but it was
maegor who could never produce a living
child whereas Daemon does succeed in
producing children
um
what one of the details in the books is
that uh when Lena dies in childbirth I
think I'm remembering this correctly
when Lena dies in childbirth she gives
birth to a twisted monstrous stillborn
which is something that does happen
sometimes
um targaryen's birth Dragon like babies
that don't survive which might be
related to their literal Blood Of The
Dragon genetic connection to dragons
um but if I remember rightly Lana births
one of those weird stillborns
um so I guess yeah that is another
connection between maegor and Daemon
they both father Twisted stillborns
which implies a sort of a darkness and a
sort of an evil in their genes
um
joburg in the live chat says that Miguel
had a narrow urethra
maegor had blackfyre not dark sister the
cursed one said he had both like mego
originally had dark sister
and then maegor's uh brother King Anis
gave the sword blackfyre to maegor and
after maegor got blackfyre he
exclusively used blackfyre not dark
sister but there was a time before he
got black Blackfire when he did use dark
sister so he did use both
um
either in the live chat says that Daemon
didn't want multiple wives he just
wanted Rainier yeah I mean you know
Daemon said that he wanted to marry
mazaria whilst also being married to to
Raya Royce but Daemon also very quickly
gave up on that idea
um like in that episode when Daemon was
you know causing a ruckus on Dragonstone
um
it really was just a bid for attention I
think and I think we can question like
was Daemon really serious about wanting
to marry mazaria and and wanting to do
all this stuff like you know he said
that mazaria was pregnant but she wasn't
so we can question whether you know
Daemon really was serious or if this was
just he was just saying crap to get a
rise out of viserys in which you know he
succeeded in doing but yeah lots of
interesting connections between um
Daemon and maegor do we want to do a
little pentoshi minute let's let's let's
do a pentos speed round
um so pentos is one of the three cities
in the East uh it is the closest free
City to King's Landing
so here is uh Westeros in the west and
Asos in the East King's Landing is over
here
and pentos is over here
uh so pentos is the city where we saw
illyrio in Game of Thrones season one
episode one this is where Daenerys met
Drogo in the arranged marriage between
Drogo and Daenerys this is our main man
illyrio here
um and then in Game of Thrones season
five Varys brings Tyrion to pentos also
in book five Tyrion comes to pentos
um and pentos is run by the magisters of
pentos
um
there is a prince of pentos but the
prince of pantos is a purely ceremonial
role and the prince goes to all the
feasts and balls and is in the place of
high honor and the prince gets all this
luxury in a palanquin to carry him
around and every New Year's Day the
prince is required to deflower the
maiden of the fields and the Maiden of
the Seas a bit of ritual sex to start
the year always a good way to start the
year but if ever the crops fail or if
ever pentos loses a war or if anything
goes terribly wrong they execute The
Prince and the Prince dies
that's what they do in pentos
um so you know it's fun while it lasts
but you could be killed at any time and
it's sort of a metaphor for you know
political figures being used as like a
scapegoat like you know sometimes you
know people in political power are in
power but sometimes power is a ruse and
sometimes it's the politicians that are
being used you know just a figurehead
while the real the real powerful people
you know the the string pullers like
Lara strong are the ones in charge
um and in pentos it's the magisters who
in charge who are in charge magisters
like illyrio and magisters like this guy
who I think is called Reggio herrerus or
something
it sounds suspiciously like Dario
Naharis actually even though Dario
naharos is from tyrosh and Reggio Aras
is from pentos I don't know whatever but
uh yeah it was cool to see pentos um and
it was cool to see that this Magister
was saying like hey Daemon you should
totally hang out you should totally put
down Roots you should totally live here
in pentos because uh pentos is worried
about the triarchy uh because we learned
this episode The the triarchy like the
crab feeders and the crab feeders
Buddies
the three daughters who have made an
alliance and took over the stepstones
now the martells of dawn have joined the
three daughters tairashmir and Lis in
Alliance with the triarchy so there's
like a potentially really dangerous
force uh coming together here around the
stepstones and like Dawn remember is not
part of the Seven Kingdoms yet
um because aegon the Conqueror took over
the Seven Kingdoms up here but aegon did
not succeed in taking over Dawn so Dawn
is still its own thing
um and now Dawn is getting in on the
stepstones so at the small Council scene
they were saying like oh God damn like
the stepstones are still a problem
apparently Daemon roasting a bunch of
pirates that one time did not solve this
geopolitical problem
um so what are we gonna do about this
continues to be an issue
um
so yeah I hope we get to see the
martells that would be cool
Helena's foresight yeah Helena did say
something in this episode that was uh
kind of a spoiler uh We're Not Gonna
spoil it we're not gonna spoil anything
here but Elena did say something that uh
next episode will come to fruition I
think
um I I really I do like Helena's uh the
depiction of Helena the daughter of
Alison and I like how she was a weirdo
playing with bugs she seems a little bit
uh what's the word a neurotypical she
looks like a bit of a weirdo that that
Elena and I think I feel like they
almost sort of leaned into the Trope of
like the uh autistic Savant or something
you know when like you know Asperger Z
people in movies sometimes have psychic
powers
I feel like they were sort of almost
leaning into that with Helena Helena's
sort of knew things that she shouldn't
have known somehow oh yeah I I don't
know I feel like they were kind of doing
that
um maybe I mean maybe Helena has Dragon
dreams like that would make sense
uh it would make sense if Elena had
Dragon dreams like viserys
um
Peter Parker in the live chat says that
Helena is the three-eyed Raven I don't I
don't think she's got um old gods Powers
because the targaryens don't currently
have
first man blood do they like the
targaryens have married amongst
themselves they've married a high tower
they've married a valerion there's no
first man blood in the targaryens yet
later on there is when aegon the fifth
egg marries a Blackwood
but uh currently I don't think the
targaryens would have old gods powers
anyway thanks for the Super Chat from
Daydream and cie
and Bolen who says can't remember for
the life of me in rhaenyra's children
are Strong's children in the book yes
yeah this is all like very faithful to
the book I think like they're making
some changes like you know Elena commits
death by Dragon instead of just dying in
childbirth but again like you know it's
plausible that there would be those
sorts of differences because Fire and
Blood is all about unreliable narration
and there's like different versions of
what really happened and so the
showrunners have to interpret and create
like a version like the showrunners have
to say you know who really was behind
the fire at Harren hall because in the
books there's like a bunch of different
theories was it viserys was it Daemon
was it Otto was it Laris and in the show
they say it was Laris so you know like
they are mostly being very faithful to
the books um Giselle says who the [ __ ]
is Helena Helena is this girl Elena is
the daughter of Alison and viserys and
she is the middle child between aegon
and amond it like they do they do have
like in the opening sequence now they
have like some you know symbols to
represent the children but like most
people won't know what that means just
check out the family tree viserys and
Allison to the parents of aegon Helena
and amond and rhaenyra and Lenor but
actually Rainier and Harwin were the
parents of joserus luceris and Joffrey
and Baylor and Rayna are the twins the
daughters of Daemon and Lena
these are the characters you need to
know
uh thanks for the super uh gizka says
did Melos kit kick the bucket yeah I I
think that Melos has indeed kicked the
bucket I wish they acknowledged it but I
think that Melos has kicked the bucket
and now all while
um is the new Grand maester
uh all while was at the small Council
this guy is all while and we now also
have uh Jasper Jasper the iron Rod is
now the new master of laws I think it's
kind of funny how like some of these
characters have visibly that's that's
iron Rod there some of these characters
have visibly aged 10 years like Lionel
looks 10 years older and beesberry looks
10 years older but Thailand Lannister
looks like exactly the same
it is difficult with the with the time
skips
um but I don't know it seems a little
bit silly to me that some of them have
aged and some of them haven't yeah
Jasper Wilde uh thanks for the Super
Chat from Travis Who Says by far the
best episode I love the increasing level
of tension what exactly does the beetle
pin mean
I think the beetle pin is the symbol of
um Lara strong like he's just sort of
taken that as his personal sigil in like
a similar way that Littlefinger takes
the Mockingbird as his personal sigil
and I think it's very silly that these
um agents of larus wear openly wears
symbol seems like a bad idea but I think
that's just for the viewers benefit uh
but yeah I think I think it's a cicada
or a or a or a scarab beetle or
something that Laris has taken as his
symbol
um Avery talks about the flavors of
Truth yeah I mean it sort of reminds me
of like the Shadows on a wall uh larus
is so much like Littlefinger and Varys
um
Danny Michael in the Super Chat says I
honestly thought the baby would survive
the fire is that possible
yeah I I was a little bit you know I
feel like they're sending us mixed
messages with the fire look as far as I
can tell in the Game of Thrones shows
Daenerys Targaryen was fireproof in the
show but no other Targaryen is fireproof
no one is is immune to fire no one in
the books is immune to fire
um I mean the targaryens get cremated
you know uh they are not fireproof
um but I feel like they did send mixed
messages when like Daemon flew through
fire on karak season he was fine but
then Lena commits suicide by fire and
yeah I I presume her unborn baby died in
that fire as well if it was not already
dead they said that it might already be
dead
thanks for the Super Chat from Shino who
says that Lena burned herself to sever
the bond with the dragon so that her
daughter might oh that's an interesting
interpretation yeah like maybe maybe
Lena you know maybe Lena's death now
allows her daughter Reina to bond with
her Dragon Vega that would be cool
because her daughter wants a dragon so
maybe that'll happen
thanks for the Super Chat from Jake zua
who says does someone else get to ride
Vega since he burned his rider yes I
mean theoretically yes
thanks for the Super Chat from k-pro who
says lots of dragons in this episode
what was the dragon in the darkness that
amond ran into early in the episode
I don't know
um yeah because amond got teased for not
having a dragon so then he went down
into the dragon pit
and he encountered a big scary dragon
and he ran away
um I guess it could maybe be dream fire
who is the dragon of Helena I guess it
could be Verma Thor the bronze Fury the
dragon of Harris Targaryen The Old King
who is now dead I guess it could be
Silverwing the dragon of uh alisane the
wife of joharis like what color is that
Dragon it's sort of a murky dark color I
I don't know it could be a lot of
dragons I mean we don't really know
exactly how many dragons are alive
um there's a bunch of them and there
could be more that aren't mentioned in
the text so far I'm really looking
forward to seeing aegon's Dragon Sunfire
uh because Sunfire is said to be one of
the most beautiful dragons like a big
golden color so um I'm looking forward
to seeing Sunfire and we saw araks
um or Vermax one of the young dragons of
just heiress and luceris
so yeah lots more dragons to come
thanks for the Super Chat from Jess who
says Elena was saying something quite
ominous a lovely strange little girl
thanks for the Super Chat from
oathkeeper65 who says Daemon did nothing
wrong he wasn't gonna make the same
mistake his brother did she died as she
lived
thanks for the Super Chat from Spencer
who says how many Night's Watch castles
are in effect right now we watched your
old video on the Doppler effect
um we haven't got a lot of information
on what's going on with the Night's
Watch right now uh we may learn more
I mean the wall has like what a couple
of dozen castles I don't remember
exactly how many castles but like there
is some stuff in Fire and Blood how like
uh king joharis's queen alisane went up
and uh got a Newcastle built and gave
some funding to the Night's Watch and
got some that like was it was it a
Queensgate on the night's on the wall to
replace like the night fort so the
targaryens have been taking an interest
in the Night's Watch and the wall semi
recently which you gotta Wonder like
maybe that's connected to uh aegon's
dream because viserys is aware of this
prophecy of aegon that the targaryens
are going to have to defeat the white
walkers so maybe Joe Harris since he was
like the one smart King who like made
good decisions for the future uh maybe J
Harrison alisane funded the Night's
Watch and made the wall stronger so that
they will be better prepared for the
white walkers I think that uh I think
that would make sense
[Music]
um
fake Anarchist in the live chat says
that maybe aljuin from Skyrim will make
an appearance
18 to 19 castles people are saying in
the live chat yeah
um thanks for the Super Chat from Benson
who says in episode 3 Harwin brings
viserys the brown heart and foreshadows
saying he's not white but he's a big lad
in this episode he refers to his sons as
Lads that's a great catch I hadn't
noticed that yeah because it was Harwin
who was like wrestling the uh stag
um in episode
three
Harwin was like holding the Stag down
with ropes so that viserys could kill it
and yeah he said the Stag is he's not
he's brown instead of white but he's
still a good lad and that is just like
rhaenyra and Lena's children they have
dark hair instead of white Valyrian hair
and that reveals that they're actually
harwin's children uh but Harwin still
loves them anyway because Harwin is
their father and you know of course
there is a very close
um parallel here with the story of
um Jaime and cersei's children Joffrey
tommen and misella who have blonde hair
when they should have dark hair because
the seed is strong the Baratheon
children tend to have black hair so the
fact that Joffrey Toman and Marcella
have blonde hair that is the hint that
they are not really Robert's children
here the hair colors are reversed just
heires and luceris and Joffrey should
have the pale Valyrian hair of rhaenyra
and Leno
but instead they have dark hair but I
mean you could make the argument like
because Leno's mother rhaenys in the
books she has dark hair because her
mother Jocelyn is a Baratheon and the
baratheons tend to have black hair so
like you could make the argument that
maybe the reason why RHA Rainier's
children have dark hair is because
rhaenys has Baratheon blood from Jocelyn
so maybe that's why they have dark hair
they could say that in this show I
suppose they won't because like in this
show they made rainys hair blonde
instead of black I suppose so that you
know it's more obvious that she is a
Targaryen
um but you know that that is sort of
like a plausible deniability that they
could use
the seed is strong
thanks for the Super Chat from
hairless oyster who says have fun be
well stay hydrated thank you hairless
oyster thanks for the Super Chat from
cie Project who says viserys and his
model of valyria giving Vibes of Bruno
Gans as Hitler in Downfall with his
model of Germania pining over the Empire
you'll never have yeah there's there's
certainly some symbolism there I mean
it's like you know viserys seems to be
paying more attention to his imaginary
Empire than he is to his real Empire you
know
like he's sort of retreating to an
artificial world that he can control
instead of enforcing his will over the
real world like he he is not in control
of his real family he is not in control
of the real world so he takes control of
an imaginary world instead
um and I really enjoyed how he's got
like a dedicated he's got like a
dedicated 40K modeling guy whose name is
eddard did you notice that like viseris
says
um hey eddard you can go now we shall
continue this afternoon at Art so
apparently like the king's personal
Games Workshop guy is named eddard which
feels like a uh fun little Easter egg
because of course Ned Stark in Game of
Thrones is called it hard
thanks for the Super Chat from
Nikki who says big fan of the channel ex
especially the Watchman one uh would you
ever consider making a video on horror
we made a video about the movie
Annihilation once uh that that's sort of
a horror movie
um yeah we we might do some other like
random movies and stuff in the future
where we are going to make more Dune
videos there'll be a June part 2 video
we're gonna make a Jon Snow video a big
character video about Jon Snow and uh
yeah always open to other weird new
shows as they come out
bit sad that raised by wolves got
canceled
um but yeah
thanks for the Super Chat from Augustine
who said did do Rainier as kids have
Dragon Blood yeah yeah they do because
you know they are not the children of
lane or they're the children of Harlem
but they are the children of Rainier and
Rainier does have Dragon Blood
but that is like an interesting question
like um in the books they talk about how
Allison and Allison's faction
they thought that jacaris and luceris
and Joffrey might not be able to control
dragons like because they have this dark
hair because they don't look Valyrian
they look more like Owen strong
in the books Allison's faction was
saying that you know they won't be able
to control dragons the dragon eggs won't
hatch for them but that is not a problem
as it turns out like we see
um just heiress and luceris controlling
their dragons here so they they do have
the Dragon Blood they are able to
control dragons so you don't need blonde
hair to control a dragon but you do need
the blood of the Dragon
thanks to the Super Chat from Elizabeth
who says Rainier is illegitimate
children are a huge mess that she's made
for personal Indulgence understandable
but the consequences will hurt everyone
yeah yeah I agree I think rhaenyra uh
was selfish like you know when she had
children out of lust I mean Jesus Harwin
like pull out game my man
um it's a terrible idea it is
destabilizing it is endangering
everybody for Rainier to have children
out of wedlock just like Cersei and
Jamie having treasonous Royal bastards
instead of having children with Robert
and like it's understandable because
like it sucks for your body to be the
property of the state like it sucks that
rhaenyra is expected to have sex with
someone who she doesn't love and who
isn't sexually interested in her and her
body is used as a vessel of you know
creating heirs uh that sucks but it is a
selfish thing to do to have these Royal
bastards which risks starting a war
so I think you absolutely can you know
see rhaenyra as culpable and guilty in
starting this conflict just as you can
see Alison as guilty you know when she
refuses Rainier's peace offering at the
small Council today
so um you can you can take different
perspectives here odd lib in the live
chat says at least have one lean or baby
I mean like that's what they said they
were gonna do
you know like last episode when Rainier
and Lena were walking on the beach
rhaenyra said we'll do our duty we'll do
what's expected of us but then we will
[ __ ] around on the side so it sounded
like they were saying yeah let's have
some children
um but but but they did it
um I'll send the live chat says maybe
Lenor is infertile uh maybe I mean they
talked about
um
they talked in the book about how Lenor
and rhaenyra like they never consummated
the marriage after their wedding which
is sort of understandable because you
know Leonard's lenor's boyfriend had
just been beaten to death in front of
him so I I you know he probably wasn't
in the mood to have sex with the the
gender that he's not attracted to at the
best of times
um but in the books they talk about how
lane or only shared rhaenyra's bed like
a few times and in the books Lenor spent
most of his time on the drift Mark
valerion Island away from rhaenyra
um and he like attended she he like
joined her for like important formal
occasions when he was expected to be
there but they mostly spent most of
their time apart
it seems in the show that they spent uh
that he's been at King's Landing with
her largely instead but uh yeah it
doesn't look like they've been sharing
sharing bed very much
uh two to Hawk in the live chat says why
not just shot shot why not just start
the show here yeah I mean they could
have couldn't they I mean like arguably
they could I mean
George Martin and Ryan Condell who
co-created this show they talked about
this they talked about how one of the
biggest questions when they were started
developing this show was like where
should we start the story George R
Martin was saying let's start the story
like early into joharis's Reign like
let's start the story
um talking about Jay Harris's children
let's show Amon let's show Balon like I
think that's the implication of what
George was saying so George wanted to
start this show in like the year
80 or something or the year 70.
um and eventually they decided instead
to show like a flashback to the to the
harrenhall council and then start the
story proper around you know the death
of Emma in episode one and stuff but
like they talk about the importance of
setting the pre-history because like if
they just started this this show with
this episode episode 6 when rhaenyra and
Alice into already adults we wouldn't
understand what that relationship
between rhaenyra and Alison had been we
wouldn't understand Kristen's history
with rainy era we wouldn't understand
daemon's history with Rainier
um there's a lot of backstory like this
is a generational story
um and we wouldn't understand the
conflicts between you know Alison's
children and rhaenyra's children until
we understood Alison and rhaenyra's
history you know and you know like
viserys's performance has been so cool
Paddy considine is viserys would you
really wanted to have missed out on
viserys and Daemon and there I rivalry
in their issues during those first five
episodes so I think I think I think that
they made a really good decision by by
giving us this pre-history
but I mean I would have loved to have
seen Amon and Balon as well if they
started even further back
I hope one day we get to see Jay
Harris's brain
so yeah I think the backstory is
important but I I do sympathize
um if you guys feel that it's it's going
a bit fast with all these time skips and
stuff
um I think you know there will be some
fewer time skips as the story gets a bit
closer to the uh to the pointy end
thanks for the Super Chat from Guinevere
and from Laura who says thanks for the
work and from Leo who says is Laris the
new Littlefinger Lara's finger well you
I mean you'll notice that Larissa's name
is similar to Varys and Littlefinger if
you come if you take the L from
Littlefinger and the Arris from Varys
you get Larice I I don't think that's a
coincidence
thanks for the super jet from gen site
who says I can't respect Kristen Cole
imagine being so salty that a woman that
a woman didn't run away with you that
you side with her worst enemy yeah this
is this is intensely personal for
Kristen
um Kristen Kristen calls Rainier a
spider who stings and sucks her prey dry
Kristen is still furious at Rainier for
having sex with him and then
um abandoning him which still like you
know reindeering was saying last episode
like stay here like you can be my secret
boyfriend just like chill but Kristen
was like no you must marry me and run
away with me or else or else nothing
um so yeah it is a bit you know it's
crazy how angry Christian is I mean some
people are like this some people do not
handle rejection very well I mean what's
crazy is that Kristen has like stuck
with that feeling for the last 10 years
like Kristen has not even begun to get
over it in fact he's more angry about it
now it seems you know and I guess that's
because of his partnership with Allison
because last episode Alison you know
created this alliance with Kristen Cole
and they sort of like they are the the
people who hate rhaenyra Club you know
like like I think Alison and Kristen's
relationship is completely based around
their Mutual hatred of rhaenyra so like
I think they sort of keep that flame
alive between them I think that a large
part of why Alison like hates Rainier so
much is because of Kristen because
Kristen reinforces her hatred of
rhaenyra like like Alison and Kristen it
seems like all they do is just sit
around bitching about Rainier all day I
think I I think that if Kristen and
Allison weren't close and didn't have
this friendship maybe they would have
chilled out but because they just create
this anti-rainira Echo chamber uh they
just they just don't get over it so I
think it is such a wonderfully unhealthy
relationship that Alison and Kristen
house but you know it makes so much
sense
I love something Kristen in the sense
that like they are both rule abiders
they are both people who have made big
sacrifices to follow the rules like
Kristen gave up everything that he was
before like when you join the kingsguard
you give up your family name you give up
your family crest and your King's Guard
becomes your entire identity your entire
purpose you don't get to leave the
King's Guard until you die like Kristen
has given up everything to become the
king's God so he is bought in like he is
bought into these vows he is brought
into this life of Chastity and that's
why he's so furious with brainy era and
so furious at himself I think that
Kristen hates himself ultimately but he
just projects that hatred onto everyone
else you know it's like when Kristen
kills Joffrey lawnmuth it doesn't make
any [ __ ] sense like Joffrey didn't
really threaten him I mean drop we kind
of threatened him but like it didn't
make sense for Kristen to be so enraged
at Joffrey I think Kristen was really
angry at himself and at Rainier and he
just channeled and directed that
violence at Joffrey and I think some
people are like that some people do
project the self-hatred and their
frustrations at others at innocent
victims
and Allison similarly like she is a real
follower she is brought in she has given
up any any kind of like outside
independent agency by marrying viserys
by having children with viserys
um and you know she feels like she's
bored in and she feels like she is owed
something for her Decades of you know
following the rules for her Decades of
being plowed by this decrepit old man
sorry Petty sorry Patty Constantine
um and Alison feels like she is owed
better than what she has I mean you know
Kristen in this scene calls Rainier a
spoiled c word
not allowed to say the c word on YouTube
apparently
um got demonetized the first uh the
first house of the Dragon explained
video anyways so Kristen calls Rainier a
spoiled which you know I think has truth
to it because you know Rainier has had
so much Freedom she gets to ride a
dragon she gets to have a secret
boyfriend she gets a life of luxury in a
lot of ways but I think you know just as
Rainier is spoiled I think Alison also
has many of the same privileges uh as
Rainier as she doesn't have quite the
same amount of freedom
but I mean Allison could right like I
mean it's not like Rainier uh it's not
like rain era like has any more license
to do what she wants and Allison has
like like rhaenyra is breaking the rules
and getting away with it Alison probably
also could break the rules and get away
with it like if Alison say wanted to
bone Kristen on the side I feel like she
probably could get away with it as much
as Rainier could get away with it
because like fundamentally
viserys King viserys is weak King
viserys does not exert his authority he
wants everyone to get along he doesn't
want to confront anyone over anything I
think Alison could get away with more if
she wanted to
like I think viserys would turn a blind
eye to Alison if she chose to broke some
rules just like Rainier is so it's sort
of like you know Alison maybe is not as
constrained as she thinks she is
in an interview with the actor Olivia
Cook
um she said that
Allison has been completely bred to
breed and to breed powerful man that's
her only function in this life it's
learning to live within this straight
jacket of Oppression how do I move inch
by inch every day to loosen the straps
whereas rhaenyra can get away with
anything
and it's so interesting that like yeah
like like why is it that rhaenyra can
get away with more than Allison can I
guess partly it's her relationship with
viserys you know like viserys loves his
daughter but viserys also loves Allison
and you know it's and it's it's it's so
interesting like how many of those
straps of Oppression like how much of
that is physical like explicit rules how
much of that is biological anatomical
reality and how much of that is like the
weight of expectation with Alison you
know how much how much of that is does
she feel constrained by her father's
expectations does she feel constrained
by viserys's expectations like how much
of that is like social psychological
weight how much of that I don't know
it's deep it's complicated
some people uh
yeah
all right thank you for the Super Chat
from
Leo and from Inquisitor
Inquisitor says that Lena's death by
Vega is nihilistic yeah I I don't
it's such a dark thing you know like
like you can see it as like this sort of
liberated like she wants to die as a
dragon rider she wants to die as a
valerian but it's also like it's it's so
dark that it like it's like putting a
shotgun a shotgun in your mouth like
it's this horrible suicide but it's also
like well you know she was gonna die
anyway so
I I I guess I I wish I got to see a ride
on Vega one last time you know
and and vegard's reluctance to burn
later it's so [ __ ] up I mean what if
the Masters were wrong you know
what if the Masons were wrong and there
was some possibility of her surviving
like like the the Pento I mean it wasn't
a maester it's like some kind of
pentashy doctor a pocket the pentachi
doctor said like we could do a C-section
to try to save the child but Lena would
not survive so at least according to the
doctor there was no way for Elena to
survive this but like God damn like what
if there was
it's horrible
Meg in the live chat says that in this
case Lena chose her death not her
husband yeah that's a good point because
like Emma in episode one you know it was
really messed up how her husband viserys
made the choice
to kill her by cutting her open in the
C-section whereas in this episode Lena
made the choice about how she wants to
die so there's definitely yeah taking
agency there I mean you know it was
notable that
um the doctor went to viserys uh not to
Elena so you know the same situation in
that sense as episode one but here Lena
takes control of how she goes out
thanks for the Super Chat from Harrison
and from parkour
yeah I think Elena Targaryen might be a
dreamer it was um it's really cool
seeing her playing with her bugs being a
weirdo thanks for the Super Chat from
bear who says hard to feel any sympathy
for Kristen dude is kind of whack
gotta agree with that
Franco says what's up with aegon
pleasuring himself out in the open yeah
I thought that was very funny
um the books do not say that aegon is a
um well he actually kind of almost does
the description of aegon in the books
says that he is lazy and sulky with a uh
more than healthy appetite for uh food
and sex he's a glutton at table swills
ale and strong line and he pinches and
fondles any serving woman who comes near
and we we do learn more about aegon's
sexual exploits as the story goes on so
maybe we'll see some of that and I did
like that there was a moment
um
in the yard when like aegon got
distracted and like was was perving on
some serving girls who were walking past
when he was meant to be training so like
I think they are being quite book
faithful here with the depiction of
aegon as a sort of a
decadent indulgent I I mean like he's a
teenage boy is the other thing like it
it kind of makes it like it makes sense
that you would get this like gross
um deviant selfish [ __ ] when you have
a teenager and tell the teenager you're
the most important thing in the world
you're a royal Prince you're better than
everyone else like it you know I I think
that is a recipe for making someone into
a not very nice human being it is
similar to Joffrey
um
and yeah I like the Betrayal of aegon so
far and I and I love that aegon is not
really interested in being King and it's
kind of like wouldn't it be better for
everyone if aegon was just not pushed
into banking if he was just allowed to
live like like if like at least if aegon
lived a life of pointless selfish
decadence at least he wouldn't be
hurting anyone or at least he wouldn't
be hurting as many people as if as as he
would if he's pushed into being King you
know I mean it's a bit like the prince
of pentos the prince of pentos lives a
life of pointless decadence maybe we'd
all be better off if our politicians
just did that
um giving actual power to someone like
aegon is where things get really
catastrophically out of control I think
so yeah I I thought aegon's um sexual
Misadventures were uh amusing and pretty
book accurate
um in the live chat milosh says why does
larus benefit from Otto's return I I
mean there's several reasons why larus
killed his father Lionel and his brother
Harwin in the fire at Harren Hall I mean
one of the self-interested reasons is
that now that Lord Lionel strong is dead
Lara strong inherit harrenhall Laris
will become the new Lord of how strong
So He makes himself a lot more powerful
but I think also like he sort of does
this crime and sort of makes Allison
aware of it and he says that he did it
for Alison so that Otto could now become
the new hand of the king to replace
Lionel but he you know it sort of like
makes Alison complicit in his crime so I
think larys is sort of binding Allison
to him like I mean I guess Alison Alison
could you know punish Laris for the
crime like Alison could publicly say hey
everybody Laris killed Lionel and Harwin
but like Lionel has made himself useful
to Allison like Laris has made himself
like the master of Whisperers for or
Alison and brings her all this important
gossip like Laris like Alison needs
Laris so and Laris knows that and is
exploiting that you know so I think that
Laris is sort of controlling and
manipulating Allison through this murder
which is uh smart and cool
AJ says is Harwin really dead yeah I
mean we saw we saw Harwin die at
harrenhal when all those like burning
burning wood fell on him so uh sad to
say Harwin is dead which is
um
which is unfortunate like I would have
liked to have seen a bit more of
harwin's relationship with Rainier I
would have liked to have seen some
intimacy with Harwin and Rainier
um I mean there's all this stuff in the
book about how like on the night that uh
Rainier tried to seduce Kristen
um she got rejected according to one
person in the book and then rhaenyra
went into the arms of Harwin and had sex
with Harwin after Kristen rejected her
is something that the books say
um I really would have liked to have
seen like what was this secret
relationship like between Harwin and
Rainier because all we've really seen in
the show is that like you know Harwin uh
carried rhaenyra out of the brawl at her
wedding with um
with lane or and I mean look like you
know I can see the appeal so I think a
lot of people would love nothing better
than to be uh fireman carried out of a
brawl by Harwin break bones I can see
that you know might light a certain fire
in some people
um you know it makes perfect sense that
Rainier would be attracted to this guy I
think but uh yeah it's a shame that we
didn't get to actually see that
relationship and you know I well I mean
I did I did like that we had this moment
of farewell where like Harwin farewelled
his children just heiress and luceris
before he left for harrenhal little
knowing that he was about to die but um
you know I thought it was really cool
how we got that sort of awkward strange
moment where Harwin you were saying
goodbye to the to these kids that he
knows are his but he's not allowed to
like openly acknowledge that they're his
kids
um be good to your mother Lads he says
and it's sort of this awkward sad moment
um and the children don't even know for
sure if Harwin is their father because
we had this moment where jacaris I think
it was just heiress like asked rhaenyra
like hey like am I a bastard is Harwin
my father
and rhaenyra like doesn't answer him she
just says that like oh well you're a
Targaryen and that's all that matters
which how frustrating is that for the
for the kid to like never know for sure
who your father is I mean it reminds me
of Jon Snow asking Ned Stark like who
was my mother
um and Ned just says oh you know next
time I see you I'll tell you but he
never does so do you think juserys and
luceris and Joffrey will ever know for
sure who their father was
will Rainier ever tell them does the
child have a right to know
it's interesting stuff
y says they kind of know now
um
juserys seems to not know
um Lavos says that Harwin died because
his name is break bones not break door
yeah yeah so we saw the moment where
like the fire started in Harren Hall
started by the Agents of Lionel strong
and Lionel woke up and smelled smoke and
it looks like the doors were barred and
Harwin was also trying to break his way
out and you would think that like surely
the strongest night in Westeros might
have a Fighting Chance
like Harwin vs door I I would bet on
Harwin personally but uh I guess laris's
agents really uh shut that door up tight
and so Harwin tragically dies
uh which sucks I I wish we got to see
Harwin like fight someone other than
Kristen Cole uh because Harwin is such
this badass character we don't really
see him do much in the books
there's a moment where Chris and Cole
beats up Harwin uh and Kristen called
beats up Harwin so bad at a tournament
melee that they start calling him broken
bones instead of break bones because
Kristen called broke harwin's bones in
this fight
um
so yeah I do wish we got to see more of
heroin I also wish we got to see more of
Lena and Lena's relationship with Daemon
and like how that worked and how Daemon
managed to get over his inability to
finish
maybe Elena knew a few tricks that
mazaria didn't I don't know
uh yeah there is a bit of a hold the
door moment here isn't there maybe Hodor
was on the other side of that door
because I remember when Hodor was
holding the door in season six
when uh when hurdle was heroically
saving bran and Mira uh from the zombies
maybe Hodor was on the other side of the
door when Harwin was unable to get
through
oh that's duck that's duck
uh thanks for the Super Chat from rulu
dos who says Notice Me shift sent by
consider yourself noticed thanks for the
donation from mace who says seeing Vega
all old and saggy makes me want to see
her at her prime along with balerion in
the conquest it would be really cool if
they made a aegon's conquest TV show and
they have talked about that being a
possibility
um they have talked about maybe doing TV
shows about other eras in Targaryen
history like House of the Dragon could
become an anthology Series where they
cover other time periods I mean I think
aegon's Conquest will be similar in that
there would be a lot of dragons and
there'd be a lot of uh violence I think
I think it could make a cool TV show I I
I heard it well it was reported by some
media Outlets that HBO did consider
making an egg on the Conqueror show and
the plan was or like the pitch was that
aegon would be portrayed as a drunken
lout
which is weird because in the books
aegon is a mysterious guy in the books
um but he's generally described as like
very competent very focused not very
talkative bit mysterious what's going on
with him but like very sort of focused
he was a smart politician he was he was
a great warrior I mean he was a little
bit like rhaegar
and I guess you know the rhaegar aegon
similarity makes sense because rhaegar
was someone who was very motivated by
prophecy
um rhaegar decided that he must be a
warrior because of something he read in
the ancient Scrolls so he might have
rediscovered aegon's prophecy maybe
aegon had a similar personality for
similar reasons maybe aegon was very
focused on
his prophetic purpose trying to unite
Westeros against the White Walkers
um but yeah aegon the conquest
prequel would be cool
would be cool
um
AJ in the live chat says that people
want a Jon Snow show I'm a little more
skeptical of the Jon Snow show
personally but yeah that is another
prequel show that they've talked about
potentially doing
thanks for the Super Chat from mace who
says Alison saying the king needs to
rest reminded me of tywin's the king is
tired moment it shows who really holds
the power yeah I I think that's a great
comparison because yeah there was that
moment
in Game of Thrones when Joffrey was
being a little [ __ ]
I guess that doesn't narrow it down does
it there was a moment where Joffrey was
being a little [ __ ] and Tywin said all
right Joffrey time to go to bed the king
needs to rest
um and so he was showing his authority
and his power over Joffrey and there is
a similar moment here where uh you know
Rainier makes a sort of peace offering
and then Alison says the king must rest
and so she sends him to bed
um and so I guess as viserys's health is
declining uh his authority is you know
what little he had is disintegrating and
Alison is increasingly taking power
Allison was was uh yeah I mean they had
this conversation afterwards wherever
Sarahs was like Hey like you totally
should marry Helena to Rainier's son
jesaris but Alison was refusing
um to one of to one of her plain
featured Sons so Ellison makes it clear
that like part of why
um she refuses to marry her child to
Rainier as child is because Rainier's
children are bastards and it is serious
like like the westerosi prejudice
against bastards is a big deal
um because they really believe that
bastards are like there's evil in their
blood betrayal is in their blood and
Allison is you know she's religious
she's very proper she follows the rules
and when you add on her personal
grievances against rain era I guess it
makes sense that Alison would not want
to join her family to Rainier his family
but if they just put aside their
differences in United it would be so
much better for everyone you know
and so yeah that's very upsetting for
Jose for uh josaris as well like not
knowing if he's a bastard and having to
deal with that prejudice I'm really
interested to see how the characters of
just heiress and luceris develop as The
Story Goes On
thanks for the donation from ludicrous
who says what do you think is laris's
motivation we already answered that it's
about becoming Lord of harrenhal and
it's about cementing his alliance with
Allison and it's about getting Otto into
hand to the King again
um thanks for the donation from
wealthwolf who says sir Krispy Kreme is
very unlikable
thanks for the donation from Sorella
relers who says any connection between
balerion's death and viserys melting
away yeah I mean we were talking before
about how
about how some targaryens seem to
believe that dragons give them strength
and like in the books Lana went out to
her Dragon Vega
um in her last moments before she died
from childbirth and also like princess
Daenerys Targaryen a different Daenerys
Targaryen her father joharis was saying
she must have a dragon like the dragon
will make her strong and healthy so so
yeah I I think that it is reasonable to
speculate that maybe
um the death of valerion sort of robbed
viserys of the source of strength and
when valerion died something died inside
viserys and he was never going to have
that that strength again
um I mean I mean it's sort of like you
know Laris was saying this episode that
children are a vulnerability in US
children
you know we we think that children make
us Immortal but really children just
make us vulnerable and I guess in a
funny way like a dragon can make you
vulnerable because you know when when
the dragon is lost or when the dragon
[ __ ] up or when the dragon burns the
wrong person you are vulnerable
um so yeah maybe viserys was made
vulnerable by balerion's death because
once you've bonded with a dragon and the
dragon dies you can never bond with
another Dragon so viserys did sort of
condemn himself to a life without
Dragon power
thanks for the donation from ranak who
says when rhaenyra proposes for Jose to
Wed Helena she proposes it to Alison not
viserys and Allison speaks for the king
and tells him he must rest now shows who
holds the power yeah yeah I mean
rhaenyra didn't ask viserys Rainier
asked Alison so like yeah it shows all
the more that viserys has no Authority
because like a royal marriage like that
is something that you meant to negotiate
with the fathers like when Carlos and
viserys negotiated the marriage of
rhaenyra and Lenor
um and so yeah we see that rhaenyra and
Alison are now Rising as like these two
competing
um
you know uh powerful people both
overriding this errors so it's a really
dangerous situation
I mean obviously like rhaenyra is the
one who should be the powerful one
because rhaenyra is the heir to the
throne and Alison isn't but you know
rhaenyra submits to Alison's will when
Alison has rhaenyra like brought to her
with her baby like it's so funny that
Alison like gaslights the shoot out of
rhaenyra by going oh Rainier you should
be resting after giving birth but it was
Alison who gave the order for rhaenyra
to be dragged up here so that she could
see the baby and check whether it was
harwin's or Lanos
like she says that incredibly like
brutally
brutally rude comment Elena where
Allison says uh to Lenor
um
uh keep trying you may get one that
looks like you
Allison says that to Leno which is her
way of saying like I know that you are
not the father of these children
um like it's it's it's like this sort of
emasculating moment where
was speaking with rhaenyra and then
Harwin came
um and Harwin sort of took over and lane
or left and it's like what would that be
like like being married to a woman
raising the kids that you know were
actually fathered by Harwin
um it's such a [ __ ] up situation Elena
like seems semi-okay with like his life
and his boyfriends and his drink but
it's like I I wonder if some of Leno's
decadence comes from a sort of wanting
to distract himself from how unpleasant
his situation is but also like you know
Lenor is blind to the unpleasantness for
rhaenyra like it's so it's so funny this
conversation rhaenyra and Lenor have
where um Leno was like oh was that was
that unpleasant giving birth how was
that did you know that I got stabbed
with a lance once
um and he sort of yeah I took a lance
through the shoulder once and rhaenyra
does not even like dignify his dumb
comments with an answer
um like Rainier just has no time for
lane or right now and I guess you can
credit Lane off for trying to be helpful
but lainer is so oblivious to what's
sort of going on with her it's I don't
know it's a complicated relationship
and I hope we get to see more lovely nor
and Rainier
thanks for the Super Chat from Sherry
Berry who says I'm so pissed that they
killed Lano that was unexpected yeah it
was quick we got such a short amount of
time with Lena played by that actor
thanks for the Super Chat from Siegel
Siegel who says you can see how Alison
sees traits of rhaenyra that she's
trying to shake out of aegon yeah that's
an interesting point that's an
interesting point because like Alison is
saying like hey like you know you need
to be focused on your political duties
and you need to stop mucking around
um which I guess is similar to how she
feels about Rainier like Alison is
frustrated that Rainier does what she
wants
um and does sort of the female
equivalent of masturbating out a window
which is uh hooking up with Harwin
um and I listen to saying you got to do
your duty you've got to follow the rules
so you know Alison is is so and I think
she's passing down what she got from
Otto
like we saw Otto with Allison like Otto
impressing on Alison you must do your
duty you must like you must prepare for
this conflict that is coming like that's
what we saw last episode
Otto was saying to Allison there will be
conflict you must put aegon on the
throne and now Allison says like the
same [ __ ] to aegon now there will be
conflict you are the crown you must be
ready for this so you know again I think
that's part of why it was a good idea to
have this sort of pre-history and this
sort of slow build up in the story so
that we could see how you know all of
this conflict all of these issues are
passed down from generation to
generation
I think that makes a lot of sense
thanks for the Super Chat from Nolan who
says do you think Daemon had empathy for
viserys seeing her choose to die by
dragon in reference to air for a day
statements
yeah that's an interesting that's an
interesting comparison because like yeah
in the same way that
in the same way that Emma Aaron died
along with her baby
after her horrific C-section and her
childbirth
um Daemon now has lost his wife and his
unborn child in childbirth so Daemon has
had a similar experience to viserys now
um so yeah maybe he does have new
sympathy now and maybe he'll maybe he'll
be able to reconnect with viserys now
like you can tell that that daemon's
relationship with viserys is still very
much on his mind I think Lena says that
like you miss him
um so that's definitely still on his
mind
vivintrol says I don't get how Kristen
is still part of the King's Guard after
murdering lenor's best friend and lover
Joffrey lawnmuth on his wedding yeah I'm
a little frustrated by that too like I
you know I think we have to assume that
Alison protected Kristen from punishment
and maybe there was some lie like maybe
Ellison and Kristen said oh you know
Joffrey Joffrey tried to assault someone
like like Joffrey pulled out a knife and
he was gonna attack rhaenyra so that's
why we had to kill him or maybe they
said oh you know Joffrey was was
spreading uh insulting rumors about the
princess uh so you know he made some
insinuation and so Kristen defended
rhaenyra's Honor by beating Joffrey to
death
um you know I think it would be possible
for Allison to sort of pull some strings
and like we know that viserys just has
no capacity to keep his house in order
um viserys just like does not like
viserys would not have put his foot down
and said Kristen must be fired I think I
think viserys may have allowed Alison to
use her authority to protect Kristen but
like you know like I would like to see
more of like what is it like for Lenor
and rhaenyra like seeing Kristen every
day the like Lena has to put up with
seeing Kristen the man who murdered his
boyfriend at his wedding like look at
this look I love when Lenor turns his
head to look at Kristen you can't
[ __ ] see anything because it's in the
dark but there is a look that passes
between Kristen and Lenor and it's like
my God like how must lane or feel seeing
Kristen every day
um I would like it if they acknowledged
it I mean personally
um if you'll indulge some more fan
fiction what I would have liked to have
seen last episode
after Kristen killed Joffrey I would
have likes to have seen Harold
westerling like stepping up towards
Kristen to arrest Kristen but then
alisoned like just like putting a hand
on Harold and saying like no like
I'm gonna I'm gonna take charge of him
like I and it could have been wordless
like it was it was cool at the end of
last episode how the whole sequence with
uh Rainier and Lane was marriage and
Kristen and committing suicide and then
Allison saving him it was all without
words I I would have liked to have seen
just just a wordless gesture from Alison
just sort of indicating like no like I'm
gonna look after Kristen I'm gonna take
Kristen to the to the godswood I mean
just as a way to indicate that Alison is
protecting Kristen from punishment I
would have liked to have seen something
like that
what is going on with the thing though
uh thanks for the Super Chat from Ina
who says are we happy with the new
actors I feel like we're still getting
to know them
um I think we can really see how
embedded both Rainier and Alison have
become like like rhaenyra in the first
five episodes played by Millie Alcock
had so much joy to her and so much like
sort of cheeky rebelliousness and we
don't see like any of that in this
episode
um rhaenyra is so just like serious and
frustrated and and sort of stoic in the
face of the [ __ ] and like and the
lies that she must tell with with the
parentage of her children like we don't
see that same cheekiness well I mean
that's kind of why I would have liked to
have seen some interaction between
rhaenyra and Harwin or more more
interaction between Rainier and Harwin
like I would have liked to have seen
some of that joy and some of that fun
between rhaenyra and Harwin because that
sort of would have made their
relationship make a bit more sense like
rhaenyra is so frustrated by like the
political front that she must put up as
Princess maybe Harwin was like the one
person she could be honest with Harwin
was like the one person who she could
have fun with and just relax with that
would make sense but like we we never
got to see Rainier alone with Harwin in
this episode before Harwin died so um
that's a shame
um so yeah I like Emma Darcy's
performance so far but I hope we get to
see more sort of layers and sides to her
as we go along I hope we don't just see
like stoic angry right here the whole
time
um Allison I think is great uh played by
Olivia Cook
um like she is this just frustrated
stick up the ass like rule following uh
bitter
um you know like I I feel like we've all
met people who are a little bit like
this Alison Hightower who feels like she
is owed more than she has and makes it
other people's problem and you know some
of it is righteous and some of it is not
um it's only been one episode you know I
liked Lena I wish we saw more of Lena
um I really would have liked to have
learned more about like Daemon and
Lena's relationship and like how they
got together because like we saw Daemon
and Lena flirting at the wedding last
episode and that was fun
um there was I mean there were certainly
like some some lust and some desire to
it but I still wonder like like how much
of daemon's interest in Lena was lust
and love and how much was political
power you know because you know marrying
Lena valerion like she is the daughter
of house valarion like the second most
powerful house in the realm she's a
Dragon Rider with the biggest dragon in
the world like like Daemon is very aware
of what that means for his personal
power so I'd love to know like how much
of their like what was their
relationship like when it was working
like at the start you know because we
only get to see their relationship at
the end when it's already sort of
starting to fall apart a bit it
um yeah I don't know it interests me
thanks for the Super Chat from Robert
who says how do you feel about daemon's
relation with his daughters yeah I mean
we did get that scene
we did get the scene like momentarily on
the roof where Daemon was talking to his
daughters Baylor and Reina the twins
um I don't think we got a lot of
substance in that scene did we
um
it was was it wordless when he was just
sitting on the roof with his daughters
and they were like grieving Lena
I don't think we got a whole lot there
yeah we yeah I think we just got like a
momentary wordless scene when he was
just sort of mourning he's dead wife
with Baylor and Reina
it'll be cool to see more from these two
and and I really like the dynamic of
like Baylor has a dragon but Rayna
doesn't
I like that as a way of sort of
differentiating the Twins and
um setting them on different paths we
saw that Daemon was like teaching Baylor
I wonder if he was teaching oh yeah well
he was teaching a Valyrian wasn't he
which again like emphasizes daemon's
interest in his Valyrian Legacy
um
I really like that as a character trait
for Daemon in the show that he that he
is very I mean I mean viserys is also
very obsessed with his Valyrian Legacy
with like his valyria model and
everything but like it's like while
viserys wants to sort of LARP with his
Warhammer 40K model of valyria and he
wants to sort of in a very sort of safe
controlled way he wants to sort of
imagine and read about valyria Daemon
wants to like make valyria Anew like
Daemon wants to be a dragon rider be a
polygamist like Break The Rules be a
conqueror fight Wars whereas viserys
just likes a sort of safe simulated
version of valyria
in the books so like Daemon and Lena
marry and then they sort of uh abscond
and run off to the east like partly
because they marry without the
permission of uh king viserys or without
the permission of callless so everyone's
kind of angry at Lena and Daemon for
going and running off without their
permission and Daemon and Rayna uh fly
their dragons Vega and karaxis around
the world for a while they go on a
little they go on a little honeymoon
across the world
um and in the book uh one person claims
that Daemon and Lena went to valyria the
ruins of ancient valyria which was
destroyed in the doom and which is now
cursed and inhabited by spooky
mysterious creatures and in the book
there's like Stone man in valyria but in
the show sorry in the show there are
Stone men in valyria with grayscale but
in the books valyria is like so cursed
that like no one goes there except maybe
for euron if he's telling the truth but
I I do like that idea of it would be
cool if Daemon went to valyria
because I mean like euron that's sort of
a crazy bid for power that most people
uh most people's balls are not Brazen
enough to go to valyria because most
people think they'll die there
um and I think since the Daemon of Hot D
is like particularly into his Valyrian
Legacy I think it would make a lot of
sense for him to go to valyria
um but you know I don't know maybe
that's something they could do later
potentially Maybe
but yeah for now though we're just
hanging out in pentos just as a little
vacation which the uh pentachi Magister
was trying to leverage for a military
alliance against the triarchy on the
stepstones
uh saludos thanks for the Super Chat
says how old is everyone now I I don't
think it necessarily makes perfect sense
how old everyone is at all times because
there's been multiple times skips and
they don't always tell us uh how long
the time skips were I mean this episode
was 10 years after the previous episode
but I wouldn't expect the ages to always
make sense because it's impossible to
cast the actors the multiple different
actors to look the right age at all
times
um I wouldn't worry too much about the
ages personally thanks for the Super
Chat from ugly boy who says do you think
that Joffrey's death in last week's
episode contributed to lenor's careless
nature that we saw this week yeah I mean
that's another thing that it would have
been nice to see like in the Gap is like
you know what was lenor's reaction to
his boyfriend's death like I wonder if
he's still grieving you know like I
wonder if part of why Lenor is sort of
disengaging and sort of doing a lot of
drinking and partying and [ __ ] around
like maybe that is partly because he's
still like trying to get over the death
of his boyfriend Joffrey like punched to
death in front of him at his wedding I
mean that would be so [ __ ] traumatic
so maybe he's sort of still wounded by
that and still in the process of getting
over that in the same way the viserys is
still wounded by the death of Emma you
know
thanks for the Super Chat from
Blackwater Braun who says how does
dragon claiming work for the children
yeah well sometimes a dragon egg hatches
in their cradle and they bond with the
hatchling but sometimes the egg doesn't
hatch or sometimes they aren't given an
egg in the Cradle so sometimes they can
claim a dragon when they're older you
just sort of approach the dragon and
hang out maybe give it some snacks you
know it's like a first date with a
dragon and sometimes it goes well and
sometimes they become bonded uh
sometimes it doesn't work out that way
there are lots of targaryens who never
bond with a dragon like you know most of
King joharis's children his daughters
specifically
so you know we don't know a lot of the
details
um
I mean it's interesting like that there
are some examples of people with
Valyrian blood later on who failed to
bond with the Dragon one way or another
so it can go a few ways and like yeah
it's not very fleshed out in the book
how exactly that usually happens so
we're gonna see more
um thanks for the Super Chat from Elliot
who says is Lena slash issue to drift
mark
um yeah who is the heir to drift mark So
currently
Lord call us valerion he is the Lord of
driftmark
um he's quite old like in the books
especially Corliss is an old man uh he's
like 60 or or so around now I think
um so after he dies you know Lena or
Lena so I guess Lenor is currently the
heir to drift Mark
um and since just just saris valerion is
going to be the heir to the Iron Throne
I suppose lucerus is currently the heir
to drift mark because he's the
um son of the son of the sun
um but I guess you might also make an
argument that if luceris is you know
he's going to be air you know second in
the line for the throne uh maybe Baylor
or Reyna could inherit driftmark instead
but what about vemond maybe vemond and
his children might have a claim to
driftmark so you know like normally like
you know Prima janitor it's the eldest
son eldest zone so like I think it would
be luceris but um but yeah that is a
worthwhile question who is the heir to
drift Mark inheritance in all its ways
are very important here
thanks for the Super Chat from Jesus or
Jesus who says Lara strong is becoming
one of my favorites can't wait to see
more yeah I I am curious to see if he's
like a green Seer with magic or if he's
just got a lot of spies because it's
still like an open question like how
does Laris know what he knows I mean
Laris did say that like you know he
doesn't know what happened in the
conversation between Lionel and viserys
so larys doesn't know everything he has
these limitations but you know it's
interesting to see he's got these
minions now like Laris has this cicada
brooch which is like his personal symbol
that he puts on these prisoners and he
and he took the tongues from these
prisoners like Lara said hey like you
know I will save your life if
you let me cut out your tongue and if I
use you as my uh personal arsonists to
kill my father and brother at harrenhal
so Lawrence has these minions now and
that's very similar to varys's Little
Birds because Varys and illyrio in the
books at least they have all these child
spies
um called little birds and they take the
tongues from these little birds at least
some of them
um and
they also teach them how to read and
write and so they're like these Elite
child spies that Paris and illyrio use
so I think that's similar to how larus
uses these people but it's like yeah
it's still an open question like how
larus knows what he knows uh he might be
walking into the mice who knows and yeah
why is it cicadas why is why is the
cicada larice's symbol
um
interesting interesting and yeah it
doesn't make sense to put the cicada
badge on his secret minions but I think
that's just for the viewers benefit meow
um thanks for the Super Chat from
Christian uh Helena Targaryen I think
May indeed be a dragon dreamer she might
have some of those prophetic Visions
thanks for the donation from Slevin
klevra who says I think I would like to
see an anthology Series in the world of
ice and fire with different episodes
depicting different eras like Valeria
Yin Etc
yeah well they're talking about House of
the Dragon potentially becoming a
Anthology series covering different eras
so that might happen
um thanks for the Super Chat from
wealthwolf who says what do you want to
see in Fire and Blood Part Two uh melis
blackfyre would be cool yeah so like
George R Martin in typical George R
Martin uh fashion
he has written Fire and Blood part one
and Fire and Blood tells the complete
story from aegon the Conqueror all the
way down to the current conflict and
Fire and Blood does tell the full story
of this conflict with marinara and
Allison and whoever else
um it does tell that full story but then
it stops after that conflict and there's
a fire and Blood part two which George
Martin says that he's going to write to
cover the next
130 years or 170 years 130 years between
the end of Fire and Blood part one and
then all the way up to the main series
uh George Martin says he's going to
finish the rest of Fire and Blood just
as he says that he's going to finish the
rest of the main Song Of Ice And Fire
series and says he's going to finish the
end of Duncan egg so it remains to be
seen if he will finish any of those
things personally I I would love to
learn about summer Hall
like I think uh George plans to finish
Fire and Blood Part Two after he
finishes the Duncan egg series because
Duncan egg will have some hole in it so
I want I want him to finish Duncan egg
first and then to write Fire and Blood
because like Duncan egg we will learn
about the black fires we'll learn about
summer Hall we'll learn about all this
the most interesting parts of that era
and I want to learn that through Duncan
egg's eyes before I learn it through the
maesters eyes you know what I mean
thanks for the Super Chat from waffles
who says unlike in got no one uses the
Night's Watch as a threat for punishment
it's probably still an honor and not a
punishment uh not quite because like
Luca more strong who had sex despite
being in the kingsguard he was sent to
the wall and I don't think that was a I
don't think that was a favor I think the
wall is sort of a punishment but it's
probably more honorable than it was
um I mean it's like you know in the
Duncan egg era like bloodraven gets sent
to the Night's Watch in Golden Fetters
and there's like a big honor guard and I
think some of his Raven's teeth join the
watch so I I guess you're right that I
think the Night's Watch is a bit more
honorable around these eras
um but I think it's still a punishment
to be sent to the Night's Watch
uh thanks for Super Chat from zavona who
says there's a shot of Daemon hugging
his daughters yeah I mean there have
been a bunch of cut scenes I've seen a
bunch of things that there were there
also was an image of um Harwin and
rhaenyra together
um in a shot that wasn't in the show I
really want the Blu-ray to come out so I
can see all the deleted scenes you know
I feel like there's some very
interesting deleted scenes in this show
that we didn't get to see uh thanks for
the Super Chat from Andre who says that
Alison is mostly motivated by paranoia
that her children will be murdered if
Rainier takes the throne yeah Alison is
trying to protect her kids here she's
trying to protect her weird ass kids and
Otto told Alison that rhaenyra will try
to kill
um Alison's children because Alison's
children are a threat to the claim of
rhaenyra's children
and I think that that stinks of like
self-fulfilling prophecy
like Otto spoke as though war was
inevitable and there's nothing they can
do but prepare for war if Otto had
instead said hey Alison it's really
important that you become friends with
Rainier it's like into Maori like marry
Helena to jaserys like do everything you
can to get along like chill everything
will be okay maybe Ellison would would
have followed that advice because
Allison does listen to her father so
much like Allison does is so influenced
by her father I mean he is why she
hooked up with viserys in the first
place I think
Otto telling Alison at this tender young
age in this emotional moment that
conflict is inevitable you must prepare
him for rule I think that that has a lot
to do with with the conflict that's
Brewing now so Otto still has his shadow
over this series and if Alison and Laris
get what they want it sounds like Otto
may become hand of the King again so uh
he may be back thanks for the Super Chat
from Eric who says does the success of
the series make you more or less
optimistic about the Winds of Winter
coming out
yeah so I mean George Martin has not
finished the main Game of Thrones series
yet we still don't know what happens to
Jon Snow and Tyrion and Daenerys in the
books because George has not finished
the books but we have been waiting for
the Winds of Winter for more than 10
years and George says I'm gonna finish
it I'm gonna finish it but he has not
um I think that the success of House of
the Dragon is probably that I think that
probably makes it less likely for the
Winds of Winter to come out because
George Martin has said that all of these
TV shows that he's involved in distract
him from
The Winds of Winter and he isn't really
able to work on multiple things at once
so he has said that that his shows are a
distraction and the more successful
House of the Dragon is the more spin-off
shows there will be and the more House
of the Dragon there will be so yeah I
think that if the show is successful we
are less likely to get the Winds of
Winter which is a real you know talk
about Faustian bargains
uh I think a lot of people would prefer
the Winds of Winter
honestly at this point but uh you know
no one knows no one knows
um thanks for the Super Chat from grv
who says did you catch the reference to
recalio rindoon oh yeah maybe Leno was
talking about recalio rindoon when he
was talking about those uh Tai roshi
people because yeah like the the
situation in the stepstones has evolved
like you know Daemon may have killed the
crab feeder but that has not ended all
of the conflict that was going on there
so like now uh dawn has joined the
triarchy against the rest of Westeros on
the stepstones
and there is also this guy called
rakalia rindoon who is this tairoshi
fellow who is fighting with it with the
uh stepstones and he was instrumental in
like pushing the westerosi out of the
stepstones and yeah like the taroshi
have flamboyant dress and uh so yeah I
guess that was who Lena was talking
about when he talked about the guy with
the Bluebeard and the crazy clothes
um thanks for the Super Chat from
Guinevere and from Tanya who says how do
you get these clips and pictures up so
fast you even speak so fluidly while
getting it uh well practice practice
helps
thanks for the Super Chat from Ash who
says love how viserys clings to his long
Targaryen hair after he's gone mostly
bald kind of the opposite of Thailand's
no-half measures head shave viserys is
all about those half measures
damn I I totally agree with you Ash we
get so many great [ __ ] smart comments
from you guys I am I'm so grateful for
this audience you guys are so smart
um because yeah viserys has this like
wispy ass old man decrepit hair
um which is a great contrast to Taiwan
Lannister because Tywin in the books
um he's got these glorious modern shops
um and he has no other hair because he
shaved his head completely when he
started going bald
um so like you know Tywin in the show
portrayed by Charles Dance you know he
is sort of balding whereas in the books
the moment he started going bald he's
like [ __ ] it I'm doing the full Bruce
Willis I'm cutting all the hair off he
still kept his glorious modern chops but
yeah like that shows a lot about tywin's
character Tywin is decisive he gets [ __ ]
done he doesn't [ __ ] about he like makes
a decision and he he he he cuts it it is
uh arrakis teaches the attitude of the
knife it is finished because it ends
here
um whereas viserys is all half measures
as you say Ash vasaris is all these like
awkward compromises that make nobody
happy he doesn't totally put his foot
down down with rhaenyra or with Allison
or with anyone and allows everyone to
walk over him and no one enjoys that
gross ass hair viserys like either cut
it all off or get a toupee or wear a hat
like just just make a decision [ __ ] or
get off the pot that's what viserys
that's what Tywin was always able to do
even in the end he he did [ __ ]
uh not get off the pot okay that's a
tortured metaphor let's move on
thanks for the Super Chat from Tay who
says do the books go into detail about
rhaenyra's relationship with Harwin do
they actually like each other or did she
know she needed to make kids soon the
books do not go into detail about any of
the relationships because the book Fire
and Blood is just a history book that
gives a very sort of brief summary of
what happened and it has like unreliable
narrators where we're not even sure
whose version of the story is true so
hot D has to flesh out all of the
relationships I I like your implication
that like maybe maybe part of why
Rainier had a relationship with Harwin
was that it was just like physically not
possible for her to have children with
lane or maybe Lena is infertile
um or maybe Lenor is just unable to get
Rainier pregnant because he's not
sexually attracted to rain era and you
know there is that idea like in the TV
show you know uh Renly had a
relationship with loris
and renley was gay uh and Marjorie at
least in the show was saying like well
you know that's that's fine
um you can still get me pregnant we'll
just like have a threesome like you know
uh Loris can get you started and then
you can finish with me so that you can
get me pregnant
um maybe Elena refused to do something
like that with Rainier you know
understandably you know
um so maybe if Lane Oil was like
incapable or just refused to get Rainier
pregnant maybe that might be part of why
rhaenyra gets pregnant with Harwin
because she's like well I need kids and
if my husband isn't going to impregnate
me I guess I guess Harwin will I think
that's an interesting take I don't think
that's what's going on like I think that
rhaenyra I think that rhaenyra has
sexual desires like like we see how
attracted rhaenyra was to Daemon we saw
how attracted she was to Kristen she had
a sexual Awakening she has desires that
she wants to be fulfilled and she
happened to do it with someone who had
dark hair and obviously you know was was
the father of her bastards I feel like
Rainier could have chosen her lover more
selectively like if Rainier had hooked
up with just some Valerian like if Ray
Nero hooked up with some valerion guy
who might give her blonde children that
might have been a smarter choice I feel
like radio could have been a little bit
more Discerning but you know love does
what it does
uh thanks for the Super Chat from fridge
who says the actor switch was great
Alison looks just like older Allison
Rainier looks just like older rhaenyra
yeah I agree I think that the actors do
look a lot like their younger
counterparts uh everyday Milo says did
Laris bang Allison or is Sir Kristen
banging Allison I don't think anyone's
banging Alison except maybe for viserys
I I think that like part of the whole
reason for like the Alice and Christian
relationship is that Alison and Kristen
are both like we are the people who
follow the rules unlike that Slaton
rhaenyra who breaks all the rules like
Kristen is committed to being a
kingsguard Alison is committing
committed to her marriage with viserys
and both of them feel kind of Trapped In
Those constraints but they still
internalize them and make them their
identity so I don't think Kristen is
[ __ ] anyone
um I I think that there probably is a
bit of a forbidden romance vibe that
they could maybe do with Alison and
Kristen I don't think they're having sex
no
um Laris banging Ellison I mean it was
interesting the sort of like uh candle
lit dinner that we saw
um Alison and Laris having in this
episode
um there is I mean certainly an intimacy
between larus and Alison for sure
um
there might be a little bit of a
romantic undertone there but like you
know I I think they are pretty strictly
business larus and Alison
um larus provides Alison with
information and occasional murder and
Allison provides larus with you know
political status and station and
protection so
um you know but I think those are those
are worth thinking about and it would
not be crazy I don't think if there was
some kind of a romantic or sexual
connection of some kind between like
Alison and Kristen or Alison and Laris
because you know Alison for all of her
repression and for all of her rules like
you know she's a she's a flesh and blood
person who has her own desires as well I
would think and I'm not sure viserys is
uh quite satisfactory thanks for the
Super Chat from mix Sims who says
wouldn't marrying the kids prevent what
Otto warned Alison about her children
being at risk she's choosing hate
instead yeah I agree mix yeah because
like if if Alison agreed to marry her
daughter Helena to rhaenyra's son
um
jiserus like yeah that probably would go
a long way to preventing where's the
bloody family tree
that probably would go a long way to
preventing potential conflict between
rhaenyra's sons and Allison's Sons
um so yeah I agree like I think Alison
did quite a selfish spiteful thing in
refusing to make that marriage because I
think that that potentially could have
could have prevented a lot of conflict
so I I do see Alison as like
villainous in this episode like she's
putting her personal spite over the
stability of the realm and I think she
has understandable reasons for it but I
don't think it's the right call and I
think that Alison's actor uh Olivia Cook
said as much in a recent interview on
Entertainment Weekly she was saying that
like Alison does Despicable things and
she doesn't try to defend them so I I I
think rhaenyra makes terrible decisions
as well you know like cooking up with
Harwin but I think that Alison comes
across more as a villain and you can see
how Otto is kind of behind that in a lot
of ways I think
uh thanks for the Super Chat from Khalid
and from ikraine who says uh dragon eggs
yeah it's not super clear who gets
dragon eggs sometimes they put dragon
eggs in the Cradle but not everyone
necessarily gets them
um I mean it's possible that aemond did
get a dragon egg in his cradle that just
didn't hatch and that's why he hasn't
got a dragon but I think we will learn
more about what that situation is as we
go along
thanks for the Super Chat from a who
says who do Lena's children marry good
question we may find out who Bayla and
Rayna marry thanks for the Super Chat
from Evan who says who's going to
recognize Larissa's sigil true thanks
for the Super Chat from Kaylee who says
I can't help but see a firefly as the
pin larus gave the prisoners I I feel
like it's a cicada but yeah I'm not sure
I'm not sure what that pin is meant to
represent I'll be interested to see what
kind of symbolism that's meant to be
I feel like it's a cicada but yeah I
don't know maybe we'll find out all
right um we're going to end this live
stream uh we're going to take a brief
look at the on the next episode preview
so if you would like to avoid uh seeing
the preview of The Next Episode you
might like to look away now
but thank you everybody for so much for
participating please like And subscribe
um if you would like to buy a uh alt
shift X t-shirt you can do that at
standard.tv Old shift X
uh you might also like to subscribe to
the podcasts there is an ALT shift X
podcast where there are some like live
stream vods and interviews and stuff
nothing new there at the moment but they
will be in the future and you can also
get all the alt shift x videos all the
new alt shift x videos are available in
a audio podcast feed so if you want to
listen to ultradex videos as a podcast
on Spotify or whatever you can do that
links in the description
uh but yeah let's take a look at the
preview
um thanks for Super Chat from TJ who
says I like that Lionel and Harwin fled
the storm and it really resulted in them
being killed yeah we got a few
um storm analogies didn't we because
Corliss uh in like episode three or
something like caller said when you face
a storm you must go through it or around
it whereas Lenor his son said when you
face a storm you should run away
which which I think says a lot about
Leno's personality versus Carlos's
personality like callus is so direct but
Leonor is like maybe you should run away
and I think that is sort of
metaphorically what lane or has done
emotionally like Leno has faced a lot of
very painful emotional problems like his
boyfriend being beaten to death in front
of him and like his wife cheating on him
and him being gay in a heterosexual
marriage and just the uh it's all too
hard so Leno just sort of runs away and
sort of indulges in drink instead
um
so yeah I like the storm analogy and
yeah like you say like Lionel attempted
to run away from the storm Lionel tried
to secure the safety of his family by
running to harrenhal with Harwin to get
him away from the danger of the varsity
coming out but he did not account for
the fact that his son larus was a
[ __ ] kin slaying murderer arsonist
thanks for the Super Chat from Modest
tuner who says if Lionel had suggested
Harwin caught rhaenyra instead of
suggesting the king except the valerion
proposal it may have succeeded yeah I
mean that's a good point because Lionel
told
um
Lionel told King viserys on the hunt
that you should marry rhaenyra to
um
lane or valerion and and that's what
viserys did he listened to Lionel if
Lionel instead said what viserys
expected him to say which is saying that
rhaenyra should marry Harwin if that
actually happened then we wouldn't have
this bastardy problem
or you know hell maybe if Rainier did
marry Harlan she would cheat on Harwin
with someone else I don't know maybe
maybe for Rainier half the appeal is
breaking the rules as an act of defiance
you know but anyway like I think that
you know if if Lionel said you should
marry rhaenyra to Harwin I don't think
viserys would have listened like in that
moment his whole issue in that moment
was that everyone was acting out of
their own self-interest and if Lionel
also acted out of his self-interest I
don't think viserys would have like made
him hand
um thanks for the Super Chat from Eric
who says has the show personally
recharged you about analyzing George's
books even with the Gap in the main
series I suppose you can only think
about the tatted Prince for 10 years wow
we could think about the tatted prints
for a few more years I was going to say
because like you know we went to pentos
so we met like the magisters of pentos
and we mentioned how like the prince of
pentos is this ceremonial position who
like nominally is in charge of pentos
but really the prince of pentos often
gets uh ritually sacrificed when things
go bad in bentos and there is a
character called The Tattered Prince
who was going to become the prince of
pentos and tatters decided you know what
I I don't want to be the prince of
pentos because the prince of pentos gets
sacrificed often so there is this guy in
the books touted prince who just runs
off and starts a sell sword company
instead of being the prince of pentos
and uh tatters tells Daenerys I want
pentos I want to take over pentos and so
there's a lot of speculation in the main
series of books that Daenerys might burn
pentox and give pentos to the Tattered
Prince like if Daenerys finds out that
illyrio in pentos lied to her and
manipulated her supporting young Griff
instead of supporting her but that's a
whole other story isn't it
um is there anything else important that
we should say that we haven't said
uh I think I think we've covered most of
it oh actually well one important thing
is that so you know last we heard Elena
valerion was not single Lena was to be
betrothed to the son of the Sea Lord of
braavos that's what they told us a few
episodes ago
um and in the books they actually they
actually resolved that uh because after
Raya Royce dies Daemon makes a social
call he visits driftmark he visits high
tide and he drops in and he meets uh
Lena valarians betrothed the the westral
son of the Sea Lord of braavos and
Carlos uh kind of hates the the guy who
his daughter is betrothed to but they've
been betrothed for so long that callus
has no honorable way to get rid of this
kid so Daemon just insults the son of
the Sea Lord of braavos he insults
Elena's uh fiance until he like forces
him to like challenge Daemon to a jewel
and then Daemon kills Lane is betrothed
in a jewel and then after he kills her
betrothed marries her
so um
there is actually a story behind like
how Lena and Daemon got together and you
know it kind of fits with how they
portray her in the show because Lena
seems attracted to daemon's sort of
dangerous dashing dragon writing like
action man you know uh Vibe so uh maybe
Elena and Daemon fell in love over the
lifeblood of betrothed her her braavos
he betrothed so there is a story to that
in the books
all right
um let's have a look at the preview and
then we'll end the live stream so
credits roll and then on the next
episode we see Rainier
your subjects must fear you oh
um bit of ruthlessness implied here
there's a dragon's gullet maybe amond is
trying to claim a dragon fire is such a
strange power yeah I mean the metaphor
of fire with targaryens it's always
about the destructiveness of the
targaryens personalities and of their
dragons and sometimes they're mad and
they're indiscriminate and innocent
people get hurt someone stole Vega I
wonder who stole Vega
um
well there's several people who want
dragons Rayner wants a dragon and emond
wants a dragon so I wonder who will
claim Vega uh there seems to be some
kind of a fight going on here between is
that Daemon killing a dude on the stairs
looks like it uh Lenor is fighting
someone I guess that's uh Carl Corey
we're in the spoiler zone now by the way
so I guess we can talk about it it looks
like this is gonna be the um spoilers it
looks like this is going to be the death
of Lenor uh to Carl Corey which is a
sort of a mysterious moment in the books
it'll be interesting to see who's
responsible
um so this looks like the uh I for an
eye incident
so you know spoilers we're going to see
uh joserus and luceris uh and Joffrey
well not Joffrey I suppose just Jos and
luceris get into a fight with amond
um and amond spoilers is going to have
his eye cut out uh by I think it's
luceris and that's going to enrage
Alison and rhaenyra so you know so much
for a marriage between them now huh
um
this is when you know the Blood starts
flowing between the boys and the blood
Feud really starts being inherited by
the Next Generation what is going on
here with the grunting and screaming I
guess it looks like Baylor and Reina get
caught up in the fight between
um Jose and luceris and amond maybe they
get involved I mean yeah I mean I guess
that's what they're saying like you know
someone stole Vega like maybe they uh
because like you know aemond goes down
to try and claim Vega and that's when he
gets into a fight with the strong boys
with rhaenyra's sons so yeah maybe
Rainier and Baylor get involved here as
well
um
yeah that looks like the incident there
uh Daemon is back in town uh he's newly
single again and so is Rainier Daemon
and rainyro both single and ready to
mingle
Otto comes back he's the hand of the
King again we can see the hand of the
Kingpin there uh larus looking absurdly
Sinister like what one of the things
that they did with Littlefinger is that
like Littlefinger in the books is very
subtle and mysterious whereas
Littlefinger in the show is like I'm a
villain like he like he just loses all
subtlety in the show
I hope they don't do that too much in
the show I hope that Laris still has a
little bit of subtlety a little bit of
ambiguity to him I don't want him to be
like an obvious villain twirling his
mustache Vega getting claimed by aemond
I I love how [ __ ] weird and saggy
Vega is she's an old murder Grandma
she's an old nuke that that aemond has
now claimed and what on God's Good Earth
is aemond gonna do with that Dragon
um Alison is mad about the one eye
incident is that Otto with amond that's
interesting why is
Otto manhandling aemond is he trying to
stop him getting Veigar is everyone
trying to stop him getting Vega
uh so you know Otto's back and so I
guess Otto will be once again pressuring
Alison into opposing rhaeny era so that
can't be good yeah he's handed the King
again
um and it looks like we get a wonderful
confrontation between Rainier and Alison
now they see you as you are so the
conflict is really starting to come to a
boil now in the year of the red spring
um so uh it's gonna be really cool
seeing this burst out I guess this
episode was sort of a introduction to
the new cast members
I mean we did also have you know the
death of Lena and so on but it was it
was more of a and the death of Lionel
and Harwin but that's a relatively low
body count as far as House of the Dragon
is confirmed is concerned so I think
that uh things may get only more bloody
from here thanks for the Super Chat from
AOE who says your weekly House of the
dragon videos are the highlight of my
week thanks AOE thanks Ethan who says
thanks for the content where's Pucci
says that Preston Jacobs will finish tea
well yeah the YouTuber press and Jacobs
does have a uh he's decided that since
George Martin isn't riding the Winds of
Winter he and his audience are going to
ride it themselves and Francisco says
love your intricate videos on A Song of
Ice and Fire
thanks so much for all the kind words
folks all right we're going to end the
live stream now thanks so much for
participating we're going to make a
house of the Dragon episode 6 explained
video which is going to come out around
Friday or Saturday uh so like And
subscribe
um check out the podcasts check out the
merch check out all stuff in the video
description linked below
and uh see you next time
thanks guys
cheers